Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge 14.
Diesmal über Atomunfälle und Atomreaktoren allgemein.
Und in dieser Folge haben wir auch einen Gast, der kommt eigentlich ein bisschen später dazu, weil wir gerade unter etwas ersperrten Bedingungen aufnehmen mussten. Unser Gast ist Michael sailer vom Öko-Institut, der auch Mitglied der Deutschen Reaktorsicherheitskonvention ist, also ein ausgewiesener Experte zum Thema Reaktorsicherheit. Da er aber nun natürlich an einem Tag wie heute nicht unbedingt alle Zeit der Welt für uns hatte, mussten wir es ein wenig komprimieren. Das heißt, wir machen am Anfang eine kleine Einführung über Atom-Energie, Atomreaktoren, diese ganzen Dinge, und nehmen ihn dann später dazu, um über Fragen zu reden, von denen wir keine Ahnung haben, und wo wir einfach auch so ein wenig im Dunkeln standen, nachdem was man so lesen kann und bei der Interpretation der aktuellen Ereignisse und auch ein wenig überfordert waren.
Und wo wir mal ein Statement von einem Experten haben wollten.
Tatsächlich einen ausgewiesenen Experten on the record haben wollten. Ja, Atomenergie. Was ist denn eigentlich so ein Atomreaktor?
Eigentlich ist es nicht Atomenergie, sondern Kernenergie. Wir müssen nicht korrigieren lassen, denn Atomenergie, darunter fallen auch chemische Reaktionen. Und davon reden wir eigentlich nicht. Sondern bei Kernenergie geht es darum, die Energie in Atomkernen zu nutzen, die bei der Spaltung oder bei der Kernfusion frei wird. Und wir haben uns mal überlegt, wie geht man da ran? Wir sind ja dann auch keine Atombauexperten. Also ich hab jetzt keinen Meiler in der Garage.
Wie hättest du nicht?
Ja, wir haben uns überlegt, ja wir erklären mal, wie man so einen Reaktor bauen würde. Und also naja, sehr... auf nicht sonderlich tiefgehendem Niveau. Aber danach solltet ihr zumindest genug von der Materie wissen, um den Rest der Diskussion verfolgen zu können.
Ja, also ein Atomreaktor ist ja eigentlich eine Dampfmaschine.
Ganz primitive Sache eigentlich, denn es gibt gar keine Methode, wie man direkt aus der Kernspaltung Energie gewinnt, sondern man kann einfach nur die Wärme nutzen, um damit zum Beispiel eine Turbine anzutreiben. Und das passiert auch.
Ja, also fangen wir mal ganz oben an. Wir haben da Atome, Atome bestienen aus dem Atomkern. Da sind Protonen-Neutronen-Böcke. Die Protonen sind positiv geladen, stoßen sich gegenseitig ab. Und der Atomkern wird zusammengehalten von der, wie heißt es, die heißt Kernkraft, ne?
Ja, Kernkraft.
Genau, und die reicht halt nicht besonders weit. Und wenn sehr viele Protonen und Neutronen in so einem Atomkern sind, also halt ein sehr schweres Element ist, dann sind die...
Da braucht man immer weniger Kraft, um den zu spalten. Weil die Selbstzusammenhalt lässt halt nach, wie größer der Kern ist.
Genau, und wenn wir jetzt...
Ab einer gewissen Größe spalten, die sich überhaupt von ganz alleine spontan.
Spalten nicht spontan, oder kommt da ein Neutronen deswegen?
Ne, es gibt auch eine spontane Selbstspaltung ab irgendwie, aber bei wirklich hohen, die in der Natur nicht vorkommen, deswegen, weil die sich halt vorher spalten.
Ah, verstehe. Ja, das kommt natürlich, natürlich, ja. Klar. Okay, bei dieser Atomkernspaltung entsteht jede Menge Energie und natürlich noch mehr Neutronen. Und diese Neutronen fliegen weiter, und wenn die dann wieder auf andere Atomkerne treffen, die sich spalten lassen, dann spalten die sich wiederum und dann fliegen noch mehr Neutronen weiter durch die Gegend. Und diesen Effekt, den nennt man dann eine Kettenreaktion.
Die Spaltung ist übrigens nicht in zwei gleich große Teile, sondern das Verhältnis ist normalerweise so zwei zu drei. Und die Neutronen werden auch nicht alle gleichzeitig ausgestoßen, sondern es gibt so eine Verteilung. Also es gibt zwar relativ die meisten, um die 99 Prozent, das kommt auf das Element an, kommen sofort raus, die anderen kommen später aus, da kommen wir später drauf, das spielt auch eine Rolle. Die Spaltung, da gibt es verschiedene Arten der Strahlung, die da frei wird an der Stelle. Es gibt Alpha-Strahlung, also die drei häufigsten, das sind Alpha, Beta und Gamma. Es gibt aber noch weitere Sachen, die da passieren können. Bei Alpha-Strahlung wird ein ganzer Heliumkern rausgeworfen, der penetriert nicht sonderlich gut, da reicht schon so ein Stück Papier, um den abzuhalten. Da ist die Hauptgefahr, dass man den einnimmt. Das sind normalerweise...
Also, dass man einen Alpha-Strahler konsumiert.
Genau. Das Problem ist, wenn sowas aus einem Atomkraftwerk oder sowas rauskommt, dann lässt sich das vielleicht als Staubniedergerät in die, wird von Tieren gefressen, kommt in die Nahrungskette. Und wenn man sowas eingenommen hat, dann reicht schon ein Alpha-Strahler, also um so eine menschliche Zelle kaputt zu machen. Und wenn so eine Zelle kaputt geht, dann kann die halt entweder einfach sterben oder sie kann sich zu einer Krebszelle entwickeln und das ist dann halt schon unangenehm. Das heißt, Alpha-Strahlen sind an sich nicht so problematisch in der freien Wildbahn. Wenn man die jetzt in der Haut kriegt, dann kann man irgendwie Hände waschen. Die obersten Hautschichten sind tot, da passiert nichts weiter. Aber das ist halt doof, wenn man das an die Kleidung kriegt oder so.
Oder einatmet.
Oder einatmet. Also, dieser eigentliche Risiko bei Alpha-Strahlung ist, dass man es zu sich nimmt, einatmet oder isst. Und deswegen halt diese Sachen, was man sieht, wenn man in Tschernobyl eine Führung macht, dann kriegt man so ein Papier, also so ein Plastesack, den man um seine Schuhe machen soll. Und da geht es genau um diese Alpha-Strahlung.
Und natürlich die Feinstaubmasken.
Und natürlich Feinstaub, ja.
Und diese ganzen Dinge.
Ja, der nächste Zerfall ist der Beta-Zerfall. Da werden Elektronen rausgeworfen. Das penetriert schon ein bisschen besser, aber das kriegt man mit so einer Stahlhülle von so einem Blech von einem Zentimeter oder so. Dann ist das auch schon weg. Und die Gamma-Strahlung ist die, vor der alle Angst haben, weil sie eben deutlich besser penetriert. Da geht also auch durch die Betonwände durch.
Ja, also Gamma-Strahlung ist wirklich übel, weil es dagegen außer richtig doll viel Blei keine gute Abschirmung gibt. Oder hält viel Wasser. Das sind so die beiden in der Praxis verwandten Abschirmungssysteme. Und man kann sich Gamma-Strahlung so ein bisschen vorstellen, wie so brutal energetisches Licht so vom Verhalten ungefähr nur, dass es halt eben auch durch relativ dichte Stoffe durchscheinen kann.
So, also wir haben gesagt, große Kerne können schon mal zerbrechen, weil das Kräfteverhältnis ungünstig wird von dem Zusammenhalt und der Abstoßung der Protonen. Und wenn man also so einen Kern zerlegt, dann wird er bei Energie frei. Das ist nämlich die energetische Differenz zwischen der Energie, die man braucht, und so einen kleineren Kern, der einfacher zusammenzuhalten ist, zusammenzuhalten und den größeren Kern. Und das wird eben frei und üblicherweise als Wärme wird das frei. Das heißt, in erster Linie ist so ein Atomkraftwerk ein Hitzegenerator.
Genau, und so sind dann halt eben auch diese Atomkraftwerke aufgebaut. Also außerdem, also dem eigentlichen Reaktor, es geht es da halt im Primär darum, wie man halt Dampf durch die Gegend leitet, abkühlt erzeugt, auf Turbinenschaufeln leitet, Wärmetauscher, die halt verschiedene Dampftemperaturen ausgleichen, beziehungsweise den radioaktiven Dampf aus dem Reaktorkern, auf Wärmetauscher, auf weniger oder nicht radioaktiven Dampf und diese ganzen Dinge. Also das ist halt, ja, also das Initiale ist im Wesentlichen eine Dampfmaschine, stimmt schon, nur dass irgendwie der Ofen halt leider eher unangenehme Eigenschaften hat.
Ja, das Hauptproblem beim Atomreaktor im Vergleich zur Atombombe, die also eigentlich relativ einfach zu bauen ist, da muss man einfach dafür sorgen, dass mehr Neutronen frei werden bei den Spaltungen, als man als reingehen. Und das nennt sich Überkritikalität. Also wenn man genau so viele Neutronen ausstößt in der Reaktion, wie verloren gehen, sodass sich das selbstständig am Leben hält, aber nicht größer wird. Das nennt sich Kritikalität. Und wenn man weniger frei wird, sodass es also nicht von alleine weiter läuft, die Reaktion, sondern nur weiter in Neutronen oder Energie zugeführt werden müssen, dann nennt man das Subkritikalität, unterkritisch. So, das Problem ist jetzt dabei, dass man beim Reaktor, wenn man eine unterkritische Anordnung hat, dann wird keine Energie frei. Das heißt, dann kann ich es nicht zum Stromgenerieren benutzen. Und wenn es überkritisch ist, dann habe ich es am Ende nicht mehr im Griff und es explodiert. Das heißt, ich muss genau das so austarieren, dass die freigegebenen Neutronen genau so viele sind, wie auch gebraucht werden in der Reaktion. Nun sind das alles stochastische Prozesse. Das heißt, es ist nicht direkt deterministisch, wie viel da rauskommt, aber man kann es eben abschätzen. Und die Hebel, die man da hat, werden wir gleich auch noch beschreiben, in so einem Kraftwerk, um das zu regeln.
Also, dass eine Atombombe relativ einfach ist, beschreibt eigentlich nur den Prozess, dass wenn es mal gezündet ist, sie zu bauen, ist natürlich wesentlich aufwendiger.
Das können wir vielleicht auch kurz beschreiben. So eine Atombombe, also das ist kein Geheimnis, sondern das steht auf Wikipedia. Das ursprüngliche Design ist das Gunn-Design, wenn ich das richtig gelesen hab. Da geht es eben darum, dass man eine kritische Masse, also das sind genau so viel, wie man eben braucht, um so eine Reaktion herbeizuführen. Na also, dass man die kritische Masse, dass überhaupt zu einer Reaktion kommt, eben hat man nicht zusammen, sondern hat man in zwei Teilen. Und wenn man jetzt die Kernexplosionen herbeiführen möchte, dann nimmt man einen normalen Sprengstoff und drückt die eine Hälfte in die andere rein. Und da kriegt man dann eine kritische Masse zusammen. Dann kannst du in der Kernexplosion kommen.
Genau, andere Designs bei Atomwaffen sind halt Implosionsdesigns. Das heißt also, man verteilt die kritische Masse zwar in einer Kugel, die aber nicht dicht genug ist, dass sie halt die Atomen nahe beieinander sind. Und beim Implosionsdesign ist in der Mitte...
Da hat man außenrum so Sprengstoff, ne?
Ja, und außenrum hat man halt Sprengstofflinsen, die halt so angeordnet sind, dass die Druckwellen des Sprengstoffs, die Kugeln in der Mitte komprimieren. Man benötigt dazu dann halt eben noch einen Neutronengenerator. Der Neutronengenerator sorgt dafür, dass man halt zum kritischen Zeitpunkt, also sprich, wenn man halt irgendwie die Bombe zünden möchte, tatsächlich auch die Neutronen vorhanden hat, die man gerade da zum Zünden braucht. Und es nicht dem Zufall überlässt, ob da jetzt ein Neutronen des Weges kommt oder nicht.
Ja, jedenfalls der Prozess, nachdem man die kritische Reaktion losgetreten hat, ist vergleichsweise einfach. Man ist einfach weit genug weg und dann kann das eben vor sich hin platzen. Das ist im Atomkraftwerk eher ungewünscht. Und ja, also es gibt noch ein paar andere Feinheiten in der ganzen Problematik, denn die Neutronen sind nicht alle gleich. Die Neutronen, die man in so eine Reaktion rein, in so einen Uranhafen reinschießt, um die Kernspaltung loszutreten, die sind relativ langsam.
Also die müssen langsam sein?
Na ja, also es geht auch mit schnellen. Naja, also es ist ein bisschen kompliziert. Wenn man eine Kernspaltung hat im Uran, die da frei werdenden Neutronen sind so schnell, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit dafür, dass wenn sie auf einen anderen Kern treffen, dass sie von dem absorbiert werden und dass der sich dann auch spaltet, relativ gering ist. Diese Wahrscheinlichkeit wird viel höher, wenn die langsam sind. Daher braucht man einen Stoff, mit dem man die Neutronen abbremsen kann. Und dieser Stoff nennt sich Moderator. Jetzt ist das Problem, dass wie vorhin schon angedeutet, die Neutronen eigentlich fast alle, also 99 Prozent, sofort nach der Spaltung frei werden. Also es gibt da, Wikipedia sagt dazu, der Zeitabstand ist bis zu zehn Femtosekunden. Das ist zehn hoch minus irgendwas. Also ja, sehr kurz. Das ist so kurz, dass man da mit elektrischen Leitungen nicht auch nur in die Nähe kommt, irgendwas eingreifen zu können. Daher muss alle Regelungen, die man an dieser Reaktion vornimmt, mit dem restlichen einen Prozent durchgeführt werden. Also man sieht schon, das ist eine delikate Angelegenheit. Und also es drängt sich nicht der Eindruck auf, dass das einfach zu beherrschen sei oder dass das gar... Also dass man das mal eben im Hintergarten baut.
Wir kommen dann noch zu so ein paar unschönen Effekten.
Es gibt noch ganz andere Sachen, aber an der Stelle sieht man schon, dass es keine Sache, die einfach ist, so einen Reaktor zu bauen. Es ist deutlich schwerer, so einen Reaktor zu bauen als eine Atombombe.
Also man kann schon so einen Reaktor bauen.
Ja, nur dass er halt...
Die Beherrschbarkeit ist dann eher eingeschränkt. Vielleicht sollte man es ja mal erwähnen, wie das halt angefangen hat. Wie halt so Atomreaktoren gebaut wurden.
Und warum sie gebaut wurden. Die ersten sind nämlich gebaut worden, um Plutonium zu gewinnen.
Für Atomwaffen.
Die ersten Atombomben haben alle Plutonium benutzt.
Die neueren auch.
Also heute gibt es auch die H-Bomben. Da brauchen wir das Plutonium nur noch als Zünder.
Aber die Uranbomben sind halt eher selten geworden. Die ersten Designs waren halt so genannte Swimmingpool-Reaktoren. Da hat man tatsächlich einen leeren Swimmingpool genommen auf dem Unigelände. Das war lustigerweise bei den Amis, aber auch bei den Russen. Da hat man Grafit reingestapelt, also Grafitziegelsteine. Und hat dazwischen Röhren freigelassen, in die man dann den Brennstoff reingeschoben hat.
Oder auch reingebohrt, also das gibt es auch.
Ja, mit so lang, ja genau, oder reingebohrt in die, in diese Grafit-Dinge. Und das Grafit wirkte dann halt eben als Moderator, also als Neutronenverlangsamer.
Wir können vielleicht noch kurz sagen, Grafit ist Kohlenstoff einfach.
Ja. Und dann haben sie da halt die Kettenreaktion angefahren. Und die, also das wichtigste Instrument, was man hat, ist halt der Neutronenfluss. Also um zu gucken, wie viel Neutronen blubbern denn da gerade raus. Und durch die Gegend. Und wenn der zu hoch wird, dann hat man halt so ein paar Stangen, an denen halt vorne das Uran dran war, wieder rausgezogen. So oder dann halt später andere Moderatoren dazwischen geschoben. Also in der Regel nimmt man halt zum Beispiel Katmium heutzutage in modernen Kraftwerk.
Na, das ist sogar noch gar kein Moderator, sondern Neutronengift nennt man das. Also ein Stoff, der Neutronen absorbiert. Das Problem ist eben, dass es nicht so einfach ist, die Neutronen zu messen, die da gerade freigegeben werden, weil man ja nur die sehen kann, die am Rand rauskommen. Also da gibt es zwar eine starke Korrelation, aber so richtig eins zu eins ist das alles nicht.
Das ist ein Problem, was die Atomenergie bis heute begleitet. Da können wir später nochmal...
Nicht nur bei Neutronen übrigens. Das ist überhaupt die Umgebung in so einem Atomreaktor so feindlich, dass man da keine Videokamera drin haben kann, um zu sehen, was da eigentlich gerade passiert. Und das heißt, Messungen sind alle so ein bisschen schwierig. Also zu dieser Neutronenproblematik mit schnell und langsam gibt es noch ein weiteres Problem. Wenn man eben nur über dieses 1% überhaupt regeln kann, dann muss man dafür sorgen, dass mit den 99% schon mal, dass man sehr knapp an der Kritikalität dran ist. Und wenn man den Reaktor gerade hochfährt, dann muss man sogar überkritisch sein. Das heißt, man muss mehr Neutronen ausstoßen, als man reintut. Aber wenn man jetzt mal sich die Zeitabstände anguckt, in denen solche Atomreaktionen stattfinden, also das kann man ganz anschaulich sehen bei der Chernobyl-Katastrophe, da gibt es eine eigene Webseite bei Wikipedia, die ich also sehr empfehlen kann an der Stelle, zwischen der finalen falschen Handlung, die die da gemacht haben und dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Reaktion nicht mehr aufzuhalten war, sind vier Sekunden vergangen. Ja, und das ist schon viel. Also man hat es da mit einem exponentiellen Wachstum zu tun, mit einer Verdopplung alle, was war das, 10 und minus 12 Sekunden oder so, also völlig ausweglos zu glauben, da könnte man als Mensch noch irgendwie Entscheidungen treffen, die Zeit hat man einfach nicht. Ja, das heißt, diese ganze Regeln ist eine sehr, ist ein sehr dünne Planke, auf der man sich da bewegt.
Einer der bekannteren Grafit-Reaktoren, wo sie halt genau mit solchen großen Grafit-Blöcken, wo sie dann Löcher reingebohrt haben, gearbeitet haben, war die sogenannte Windscale-Anlage in Großbritannien, wo es dann halt auch mal ganz spektakulär schiefgegangen ist. Da gibt es eine großartige BBC-Doku zu. Grafit hat nämlich so ein paar unschöne Eigenschaften. Eine davon ist das, also außer, dass es brennen kann, eine davon ist, dass die Kristallstruktur von Grafit kann sich anreichern mit Energie, wenn sie halt mit Neutronen beschossen wird.
Und nochmal, wir sollten vielleicht kurz erklären, was den Stoff eigentlich zum Moderator macht. Und zwar ist das, hauptsächlich ist der Punkt, dass der Kern von dem Moderatorstoff nicht deutlich größer ist als die Neutronen selbst. Also das heißt, man muss ein Element, eine kleine Massenzahl nehmen und das ist also entweder Wasserstoff bietet sich dann natürlich an, weil das ist der geringsten ist, aber Kohlenstoff ist halt auch ein sehr kleines Element und deswegen eignet es sich dazu. Man hat nicht die große Auswahl, will ich damit sagen. Das heißt, Graphit und Wasser sind so die, die da gerne genommen werden, aber man kann da nicht irgendwie beliebig, kann ich einfach Eisen nehmen zum Beispiel.
Genau diese Frage, wie groß der sogenannte Neutronenquerschnitt ist, also wie es sich verhält, wenn man Neutronen darauf schießt, ist halt auch eine Frage an vielen anderen Stellen der Kerntechnik. Zum Beispiel hört auch bei den Hüllen für die Brennstäbe, dem Zirkonium, da kommen wir auch nochmal später dazu.
Vielleicht noch eine kleine Nomenklatursache. Die Neutronen, die direkt aus der Spaltung rausfallen, heißen schnell und die gebremsten heißen thermisch. Thermisch deswegen, weil wenn so ein Neutronen mit dem Moderator kollidiert und dabei Energie abgibt und dann nochmal kollidiert und wieder Energie abgibt, dann geht die Energie im Moderator auch in Sachen Temperatur raus. Das wird also als Wärme übertragen am Ende. Es ist so, dass die Neutronen von ihrem Energielevel ungefähr eine ähnlich hohe Energie haben wie der Moderator. Und weil das eben von der Größenordnung her Temperatursache ist, sagt man eben thermisch an der Stelle. Aber der Punkt, dass die Neutronen schnell heißen, wenn sie ungebremst sind vom Moderator, da kommt der Name schneller Brüter her, den ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon immer gehört habt in der Berichterstattung. Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass der irgendwie schnell brütet, sondern dass die Neutronen schnell und unmoderiert sind in dem. So, weiter.
Genau, gut, wir waren gerade noch bei Windscale. Also Windscale, wie gesagt, die Doku ist extrem sehenswert, weil sie die, ja, also eigentlich alle Probleme des Atomzeitalters in einem, ja, in einer schönen Stunde zusammenkomprimiert. Was sie da getan haben, war halt einen großen Grafitreaktor zu fahren, in dem sie Plutonium gebrütet haben. Und das Plutonium brüten funktionierte halt so, dass sie halt einfach so Kartuschen mit Brennstoff genommen haben, wieder reingeschoben haben und die eine Weile brütet haben. Und wenn sie dann damit fertig waren, dann haben sie die hinten rausgeschoben, dann sind sie hinten in den Wassergraben gefallen und haben dann halt Platsch gemacht und sind dann abgekühlt worden.
Das war übrigens luftgekühlt damals noch, das gibt es heute gar nicht mehr.
Sie haben da große Ventilatoren dran gehabt, mit denen sie da durchgeblasen haben durch den Reaktor.
Und jetzt kann man sich schon vorstellen, Luft, wenn man so ein Feuer hat und da Luft gegenpustet, das ist nicht unbedingt eine gute Idee, um das Feuer zu löschen, im Gegenteil. Und genau das ist ihnen auch zum Verhängnis geworden. Denn Grafit hat den Nachteil, dass es bei sehr hohen Temperaturen zu brennen anfangen kann.
Und es hat noch den anderen Nachteil eben diese besagte Wigner-Energie. Wenn man da mit Neutronen draufschießt, ändert sich die Kristallstruktur des Grafites in einer Art und Weise, dass Energie gespeichert wird. Und die wird dann halt zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt spontan frei. Das heißt also, dass Grafit, wenn es halt relativ bestrahlt wird, wenn man mit Neutronen bestrahlt wird, bindet diese Wigner-Energie und die wird dann zu einem relativ unvorhersehbaren Zeitpunkt frei und dann wird es warm.
Das sind doch Hotspots, das ist nicht homogen. Das kommt auch dazu. Das heißt, das bringt einem auch die ganzen Kalkulationen durcheinander.
Deswegen müssen halt in diesen Grafit-Reaktoren, die müssen sie gelegentlich durch so Temperaturzyklen fahren, wo sie die einfach überhitzen, um die Kristallstruktur wieder herzustellen. Gerade zu bügeln. Kann man sich so, das ist so ähnlich der Prozess, wie halt beim Härten von Stahl, den man ja auch durch Temperaturkurven fährt. Also mit warm machen und abkühlen, um halt eine bestimmte Kristallstruktur zu erreichen. Genau sowas mussten sie dann damit auch machen. Und einer dieser Prozesse ist ihnen dann schiefgegangen bei dieser Windskill-Anlage, weil sie halt angefangen haben, an den Designparametern der Anlage rumzuspielen und also die Kühlkapazität zu reduzieren, um heißer brüten zu können, um mehr Plutonium rauszubekommen. Und dann im späteren Schritt haben sie noch Lithium bebrütet, um Tritium für Wasserstoffbomben zu erzeugen. Und dann ist es ihnen endgültig schiefgegangen, dann hatten sie da halt so ein glühendes Feuer, wo ihnen halt einfach der Uran-Kram in diesem Reaktor geschmolzen ist und vorne pusteten die Ventilatoren und dies kühlen sollten und fachten das Feuer noch an. Und am Ende haben sie es irgendwie nur dadurch in den Griff bekommen, dass sie da ein paar Helden reingeschickt haben, die da Wasserschläuche reingesteckt haben.
Und also der Punkt, den wir vorhin schon angekündigt haben, dass wir darauf noch ein paar Mal zurückkommen werden. Sie haben es nicht gemerkt, dass das Grafit brennt, bis der heldenhafte Reaktorführer sich da unter persönlicher Lebensaufgabe in einem Schutzanzug einfach hinbegeben hat und geguckt hat. Denn so ein Reaktor zu überwachen ist einfach kein Selbstläufer. Das heißt, üblicherweise ist die Sensorik sehr eingeschränkt, insbesondere nach Störfällen. Da kann man also nicht von ausgehen, dass sie genügend Instrumentarium am Start haben, um dann die Situation ordentlich diagnostizieren zu können. Der Punkt, als ich das so richtig begriffen habe, war, als ich diese Three Mile Island-Sache gesehen habe. Three Mile Island war ein US-Reaktor, der hat auch einen Störfall gehabt in den 70s. Und da gibt es auch eine Dokumentation, die wir dann verlinken werden. Da gab es diesen sehr interessanten Punkt, dass sie halt die ganze Zeit gedacht haben, na ja, na ja so, wir haben es ja überlebt, es ist ja noch nicht geplatzt, also schlimm kann es ja nicht gewesen sein. Und haben ihn dann zwar ausgestellt und abkühlen lassen. Aber als sie dann nach drei Monaten eine Sonde reingeschickt haben, haben sie bei der Gelegenheit erst gemerkt, dass sie eine Kernschmelze gehabt haben. Ja, und das würde man ja eigentlich denken, wenn man so einen Reaktor baut, ist ein Event, was man eigentlich zeitnah erfahren möchte, wenn man gerade eine Kernschmelze hat. Aber so ist das eben nicht in der Technik, dass man das gut sehen kann von außen, dass man da irgendwie eine Lampe hat, die dann angeht. Sondern das sind alles irgendwelche Indizienbeweise, die dann die Alarme triggern, da wird es halt zu warm oder der Druck steigt oder so.
Wo es dann auch häufiger mal mehrere Möglichkeiten für die Indizien gibt, also was irgendwie...
Gerade bei diesem Windscale war es halt so, das ist halt wärmer geworden wegen des Grafitbrandes und sie haben halt gedacht, das ist diese Wigner-Energie und haben es dann heißer gemacht, um die Wigner-Energie abzulassen und damit haben sie einfach nur das Feuer schlimmer gemacht. Und diese Art von von selbst aufschaukelnden Effekten gibt es halt mehrfach in der Kernenergie.
Also einer dieser Effekte ist die Xenon-135-Anreicherung, die Xenon-Vergiftung, die führte dazu, dass...
Bei Tschernobyl jetzt.
Bei Tschernobyl, genau. Also was es tut, ist Xenon-135 frisst...
Ist ein Isotop, also ist nicht das normale Xenon, sondern ist ein Isotop.
Ja, und es entsteht halt irgendwie bei der Kernspalte einer solchen Grafiedireaktoren und es frisst halt den Neutronen.
Das ist ein Neutronengift, ja.
Die Xenon-Vergiftung funktioniert so, dass auch nach dem Abschalten des Reaktors noch mehr Xenon-135 durch Spaltprodukte gebildet wird, aber dadurch, dass die Neutronenflussrate geringer ist, dann wird der... wird das nicht mehr abgebaut. Also im Betrieb, wenn also Neutronenflussrate hoch ist, wird das ungefähr genauso viel abgebaut wie aufgebaut. Aber wenn die Neutronenflussrate niedrig ist, dann reichert sich das an. Das heißt also, wenn man in den Raktor dann wieder hochfährt oder anfährt, dann muss man halt erst mal diese Xenon 135 wie so einen Gummipuffer überwinden. Und wenn man dann halt nicht rechtzeitig wieder die Leistung runterfährt, um den Abbau des Xenons zu kompensieren, dann hat man halt irgendwie ein Problem. Und von solchen Effekten gibt es halt in der Krantechnik einige. Und die muss man halt auch berechnen. Und da kommen wir dann später mit dem Michael sailer auch nochmal ein bisschen genauer im detail auf.
So, wir haben die Komponenten fast zusammen für so einen Reaktor. Wir haben einen Haufen Uran, wir haben eine Neutronenquelle, um das zu zünden. Wir haben einen Moderator. Das reicht aber immer noch nicht, denn man muss ja steuern können, dass die Kritikalität erhalten bleibt. Ja, wie macht man das? Das macht man, indem man einen Kontrollstäbe hat. Das habt ihr bestimmt auch schon gehört in der Diskussion.
Steuerstäbe genannt.
Steuerstäbe, genau. Und das ist normalerweise ein Material, genau wie Xenon, aber das nimmt man halt nicht, weil es ein Gas ist, sondern es ist halt ein Material, was Neutronen aufnimmt.
Die beliebtesten Materialien dafür sind...
Katmium und Bohr.
Katmium und Bohr, genau. Und Bohr, wenn wir heute noch häufiger hören, habt ihr bestimmt auch schon in den Nachrichten gehört.
Das haben wir die Japaner jetzt auch in großem Stil aus Südkorea importiert gerade.
Ja, Bohr ist halt ein Neutronengift, also mit dem man den Neutronenfluss im Wasser, wenn man Wasser als Moderator hat, dramatisch reduzieren kann. Und Katmium ebenso. Das heißt, wenn man den Reaktor ein bisschen kleiner drehen will oder runterfahren will, dann fährt man diese Steuerstäbe da rein, die dann halt die Neutronen vergiften, also sie werden halt weggefressen. Wichtig noch für die Diskussion im Japan ist halt noch die Unterscheidung zwischen den Reaktortypen, die wir haben.
Also die beiden häufigsten sind beides Leichtwasserreaktoren. Leichtwasser ist das normale Leitungswasser, was wir haben. Im Vergleich dazu gibt es auch schweres Wasser, das ist ein Isotop, das relativ teuer zu beschaffen ist. Als die Nazis an ihren Nuklearprogrammen geforscht haben, haben sie also schweres Wasser als Moderator verwenden wollen. Und haben es nicht gehabt und das fiel eigentlich in größerer Menge nur in Norwegen ab. Die haben nämlich ein Wasserkraftwerk gehabt.
Na die haben tatsächlich eine Kaskade gebaut, mit der sie eine schwere Wasseranregung gemacht haben.
Die haben es aber nicht gebraucht eigentlich, sondern es fiel einfach ab. Wofern haben die es gebraucht?
Die haben sie tatsächlich absichtlich erzeugt. Das fällt nicht einfach ab. Das Wasserkraftwerk brauchten sie, um diese Kaskade zu betreiben, weil tierisch energieintensiv war.
Wozu brauchten die denn schwere Wasser?
Na für Kernfaschung. Moskito wurde tatsächlich absichtlich produziert.
Also jedenfalls heißt es sozusagen, dass die Nazis überhaupt in Richtung Norwegen gegangen sind, lag zum Gutteil daran, dass sie das schwere Wasser haben.
Ja, sie wollten noch ein bisschen mehr haben. Das ist so die Verschwörungstheorie. Am Ende wollten sie es halt haben und sie haben es halt bekommen. Und die Briten und der norwegische Widerstand haben halt intensiv versucht, sie daran zu hindern.
Auch durchaus erfolgreich. Die haben jetzt ein Boot versenkt.
Zu bekommen. Und da gab es halt eine längere Geschichte. Hier verlinken wir auch noch. Die Norsk-Hydrow waren eine der ersten Special Forces-Operationen, würde man heute sagen, wo sie intensiv trainiert haben, eine spezifische Anlage zu vernichten. Die haben in Großbritannien nach Bauplänen und nach Augenzeugenberichten eine Mock-up-Anlage gebaut, also aus Holz, in der sie die Leute, die es dann sprengen sollten, trainiert haben. Es gab einen ersten Versuch, der ist ein bisschen viel geschlagen. Und dann gab es einen zweiten Versuch, der war dann erfolgreich. Da ziemlich heldenhaft im Einsatz. Also sind auch nicht alle durchgekommen. Und dann haben sie halt diese Kaskaden da gesprengt. Also die Geschichte ist wirklich sehr lesenswert, weil auch unter dem Gesichtspunkt, dass es halt so eine der ersten Konterproliferationsoperationen war. Also die sozusagen die erste groß angelegte Mit-Tier-Operation, die mit ziemlich großem Aufwand betrieben wurde, um halt einen Gegner am Erwerb von Nuklearmaterial zu hindern. Nach den verschiedenen Aktionen, die es halt vorher auf Kontinentaleuropa gab, um die Nazis daran zu hindern, an die Uranvorkommen der oberen Länder zu kommen. Da gab es auch einige wilde Geschichten. Jedenfalls haben sie dann halt diese Anlage gesprengt. Und die haben sie dann wieder aufgebaut. Also hat aber ziemlich lange gedauert. Also da lag die Produktion erst mal brach. Und dann haben die Nazis versucht, die Vorräte, die schon da waren, an schweren Wasser und dem Wasser, was dann erzeugt wurde, halt nach Deutschland zu evakuieren. Und dann haben sie es tatsächlich geschafft, der norwegische Widerstand an Bord der Fähre, also gibt es halt eine Stelle, wo sie über so einen See mussten. Und die, also auf dem Weg nach Deutschland mit diesen Fässern, mit dem schweren Wasser. Und dann haben sie es tatsächlich geschafft, die an Bord dieser Fähre eine Bombe unterzubringen und diese Fähre zu versenken mit den Tonnen mit dem schweren Wasser drauf, sodass die Deutschen halt dann keine großen Mengen schweres Wasser bekommen haben. Also man sieht schon die strategische Materialien. Da fällt auf jeden Fall schweres Wasser drunter. Ja, also jedenfalls im Normalbetrieb haben wir halt irgendwie Leichtwasserreaktoren. Da haben wir zwei Typen. Der eine ist der sogenannte Druckwassereaktor. Das ist das, was in Deutschland am häufigsten ist. Das heißt, da haben wir einen Reaktorkessel, der steht in der Druck. So wie so ein Teekessel, den man zuklebt. Sollte man nicht machen, jedenfalls.
Nein, wir haben auch Siedelwasserreaktoren, so ist das nicht.
Ja, aber die meisten sind Druckwassereaktoren, glaube ich. Und in dem...
Na ja, das hilft ja nicht. Ich meine, wenn einer explodiert, ist dir doch egal, ob die anderen alle...
Na gut, aber der wesentliche Unterschied zwischen einem Druckwassereaktor und einem Siedelwasserreaktor, den sollte man schon mal erwähnen, ist, dass bei einem Druckwassereaktor gibt es halt mehrere Wärmetauscherkreisläufe. Das heißt also, der radioaktive Dampf, der halt, bzw. das unter Spannung stehende Wasser, was da erzeugt wird, wird über Wärmetauscher erst nach draußen seine Energie abgeben auf die Turbinen. Wohingegen bei einem Siedelwasserreaktor, der halt unter wesentlich geringerem Druck gefahren wurde, also so ein Druckwassereaktor geht bis 150 bar, so ein Siedelwasserreaktor signifikant weniger.
So 70 so.
Da wird halt der radioaktive Dampf direkt aus dem Reaktorkessel auf die Turbinen geblasen. Heißt also bei einem Siedelwasserreaktor ist der radioaktive Bereich, also wo halt einfach der radioaktive Dampf langkommt, sehr viel größer und also sehr viel offener, weil halt da die ganzen Turbinen dranhängen.
Fukushima sind Siedelwasserreaktoren.
Genau, Fukushima sind Siedelwasserreaktoren. Das heißt also da hat man signifikant größeren offenen Kreislauf, was auch heißt, dass es halt sehr viel mehr Schnittstellen sozusagen in die Außenwelt gibt, aus dem Reaktorkessel raus. Das ist so ein bisschen der grobe Hintergrund.
Also ein Problem von den Reaktor-Designs mit Leichtwasser ist, dass nur relativ wenig von dem spaltbaren Material tatsächlich benutzt wird, wenn man so einen Uranhaufen aus der Natur nimmt. Also das erste Problem ist, wenn man Leichtwasser hat, man kann nicht einfach Naturoran nehmen, sondern man muss es anreichern. Anreichern heißt an der Stelle, Naturoran ist Uran 238 und es gibt ein Isotop, das kommt mit ungefähr 0,7 Prozent vor in der freien Wildbahn, Uran 235 und den Anteil davon muss man auf 4 Prozent erhöhen. Das ist relativ aufwendig, da gibt es verschiedene Verfahren. Am Anfang hat man irgendwelche Gas-Diffusionssachen gemacht, heute benutzt man Zentrifugen. Aber das ist ein sehr aufwendiger und schwieriger und teurer Prozess, das Anreichern. Das muss man allerdings tun. Wenn man das getan hat und damit seine Brennelemente baut und die in so einem Leichtwasserreaktor einsetzt, bis sie durch sind, dann hat man immer noch 99 Prozent übrig. Weil dann ist zwar, also dann ist die Schwelle unterschritten, dass daraus eine kritische Reaktion werden kann.
Also eine ökonomisch sinnvolle Kettenreaktion, muss man sagen.
Man müsste halt mehr Energie dazu führen, damit es an die Neutronen bringt und keine Kettenreaktion mehr.
Naja, beziehungsweise sinkt halt die Leistung ab, weil die Neutronenflussdichte sinkt. Also ist ja so, dass die Brennelemente in kommerziellen Reaktoren werden nie so lange gefahren, bis sie tatsächlich so abgelutscht sind, dass gar nichts mehr geht. Sondern die werden halt so lange gefahren, bis sie halt irgendwie eine signifikante Unterschrettung der Nennleistung produzieren. Das ist halt der wesentliche Punkt. Aber da kommt man nachher mit Michael sailer drauf.
Aber wenn so ein Brennstab kommerziell durch ist, dann ist immer noch praktisch alles von dem Brennmaterial drin. Deswegen kann man die auch wieder aufbereiten. Da hat sich vielleicht auch der eine oder andere gefragt, was das eigentlich heißt, wenn man so einen Brennstab wieder aufbereitet.
Aber ich glaube, das muss man nochmal separat behandeln.
Das machen wir nochmal separat.
Wie die Aufbereitung funktioniert.
Ja, so das ist das eine Problem. Das andere Problem ist, dass es ja auch noch andere spaltbare Materialien gibt, die aber von sich aus nicht so ein Isotop haben, was man anreichern könnte, zum Beispiel Thorium. Da kommt eigentlich nur ein Isotop vor in der freien Wildbahn. Aber das kann man trotzdem benutzen. Nur halt nicht in Leichtwasserreaktoren. Da gibt es einen anderen Reaktortyp für den Brutreaktor. Mit Brutreaktoren kann man auch Plutonium benutzen. Das ist sozusagen eine neue Generation von Reaktoren. Deutschland hat auch mal einen gebaut, das war Kalkar. Der ist auch fertig geworden, aber nie ans Netz gegangen, weil da ist ein Schando-Bild dazwischengekommen.
Das ist auch nie bestückt worden, also das jetzt...
Ein Brutreaktor funktioniert signifikant anders als ein Leichtwasserreaktor. Die haben als Moderator sowas wie Natrium, also Flüssigmetall, und haben keinen Moderator. Also das Natrium ist nur Kühlmittel. Das Problem ist, dass Wasser als Kühlmittel selber einen zu hohen Anteil der Neutronen aufnimmt. Deswegen geht Wasser nicht an der Stelle. Und wer in Chemie aufgepasst hat, weiß, dass Natrium ausgesprochen unfreundlich ist. Wenn das irgendwie mit Wasser in Verbindung kommt, gibt das eine starke exotherme Reaktion. Und das ist natürlich ein echtes Risiko bei diesen Reaktoren. Das heißt, wenn man sich mal bestehende Brüterreaktoren ansieht und da auf die Störfälle guckt, sind das in den wenigsten Fällen irgendwelche Kernschmelzen, sondern das sind fast immer irgendwelche Natriumprobleme. Das haben wir nachher auch noch mal mit unserem Experten angesprochen. Die Temperatur ist auch signifikant höher. Das heißt, das Material, was man da braucht und die Anforderungen an das Material sind deutlich höher. Und da stößt man eben an die Grenzen.
Also der ehemalige deutsche Brutreaktor an Kalkar ist mittlerweile das Kernwasser Wunderland.
Ja, das ist ganz witzig. Der hat, wie viel waren das am Ende, 2,5 Millionen oder so gezahlt? Und macht jetzt einen Vergnügungspark?
Ja, der gibt es. Das heißt Kernies Wunderland. Also früher mal Kernwasser Wunderland genannt. Und ist jetzt halt ein Freizeitpark. Also so viel zur Frage. Also man kann, bevor man da radioaktive Substanzen einbringt, kann man diese Kraftwerksgebäude tatsächlich noch recyceln und da irgendwas Sinnvolles draus machen. Und sei es auch nur ein Kernwasser Wunderland-Park. Danach ist es dann ein bisschen schwieriger.
So, also wenn man jetzt so einen Brutreaktor hat und man hat drinnen ein Natrium-Kreislauf und man hat draußen ein Wasserkreislauf, damit man Dampf hat und Turbinen betreiben kann und es gibt irgendein Problem und das Wasser kommt mit dem Natrium zusammen, dann ist es so schwer zu containen, dass die Brutreaktoren noch einen dritten Kreislauf haben. Die haben also einen Innennatrium-Kreislauf, der eben auch radioaktiv wird, weil er innerhalb des Reaktors ist und dann draußen haben sie nochmal einen Natrium-Kreislauf und erst der hat einen Wärmetauscher zu dem äußeren Dampf-Kreislauf. Also man sieht auch, obwohl da diverse Sicherheitsfeatures eingeplant sind, so richtig wohl ist eigentlich niemandem dabei und auch schon bei den Designs von diesen Reaktoren hat man eben lieber noch einen Kreislauf mehr gemacht.
So Natrium-Reaktoren haben von halt primar militärischen Bereich ausprobiert am Anfang. Und es war halt so zickig und so problematisch, dich zu kriegen, dass selbst die Russen ihre U-Boot-Reaktoren nicht mehr mit Natrium gekühlt haben, sondern die halt auch bei Blei-Bismuth ausgewichen sind. Was auch so der Standard war bei diesen ganzen anderen kompakten Reaktoren, auch bei den Amis. Aber das ist halt so, naja, man kann sich da ungefähr vorstellen, was passiert, wenn man so ein Reaktor komplett runterfährt und der ist halt mit Blei voll.
Also Blei ist auch unerfreulich, weil das eben hoch gesundheitsschädlich ist. Aber wenn man sich vorstellt, so ein U-Boot ist ja im Wasser. Und wenn es da irgendwie ein Problem mit dem containment gibt und das Natrium austritt, das ist halt, ja, das will man nicht. Natrium ist aber nur eins der Probleme mit so einem Brutreaktor. Ein anderes Problem ist, dass der nicht eigenstabil ist. Eigenstabilität ist beim Leichtwasserreaktor ein Regelkreislauf, der mal zur Abwechslung für uns arbeitet, wenn man nämlich versehentlich oder absichtlich die überkritische Reaktion erreicht in einem Leichtwasserreaktor. Dann wird ja vor allem die Hitze erst mal stärker und das sorgt eben dafür, dass das Wasser Dampfblasen erzeugt oder gleich ganz verdampft. Und dadurch ändert sich die Dichte von dem Wasser. Und wenn die Dichte abnimmt, dann nimmt auch der Moderator-Effekt ab. Das heißt, die Neutronen werden weniger gebremst und dadurch nimmt automatisch auch die Kettenreaktion wieder ab. Das heißt, man hat so einen kleinen Regelkreislauf, der dafür sorgt, dass es eben nicht von sich aus zur Atombombe wird. Das hat man nicht bei Grafit und das hat man auch nicht bei Wot-Reaktoren. Da muss man also regeln. Und das ist ja immer eine Sache, da freut sich der Ingenieur. Aber auf der anderen Seite der Typ, der die Folgekostenabschätzung macht und der sich Gedanken macht über die Risiken, der ist halt unerfreut darunter. Und das hat sich also auch nie wirklich durchgesetzt. Es gab zwar diverse Versuche, sowas zu bauen. Und es gibt auch welche, die gebaut worden sind. Frankreich hat einen relativ großen gehabt, Super-Fenix. Der zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass die lokale Bevölkerung so unzufrieden von der Idee war, dass da so ein Reaktor gebaut wird, dass die mit einer vom Schwarzmarkt besorgten russischen Raketenwerfer, damit haben die auf den Reaktor geschossen. Der war noch nicht in Betrieb an der Stelle. Aber haben wohl das Gebäude mehrfach getroffen und auch kurz neben dem containment eingeschlagen. Das wäre also wohl nicht so erfreulich gewesen, wenn der schon in Betrieb gewesen wäre. Verzosen haben wir halt so etwas anderes. Gut, aber so richtig populär war die Idee noch nie. Hätte allerdings den Vorteil, das ist sozusagen das eine große Argument für Bruttreaktoren, dass man damit eben eine deutlich höhere Ausnutzung erreicht. Also theoretisch 100 Prozent, soweit ist man aber in der Praxis nie gekommen. Eher so 60 Prozent. Wir sollten vielleicht noch sagen, warum man überhaupt angedacht hat, dass man mehr nutzen will, denn das Uran ist auch sehr endlich. Wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass nicht noch mehr Atomreaktoren gebaut werden, was ja nicht der Fall ist, es werden ja mehr gebaut, aber da werden halt auch immer wieder welche abgeschaltet, dann reicht unser Uran noch so was, 60 Jahre, das glaube ich die Schätzung gar nicht.
Ja, irgendwas zwischen 60 und 90 Jahren sind so die...
Also Uran hält auch nicht ewig auf Deutsch.
Ja, naja und was macht man mit diesen Brennelementen, wenn sie hinten übrig bleiben? Das ist ja gerade auch bei Japan irgendwie eines der heißen Themen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Tja, dann hat man verloren. Da gibt es kein gutes Konzept für...
Da gibt es kein gutes Konzept für, also es gibt halt irgendwie kein ordentliches Endlager, aber da reden wir gleich drüber. Und über das, was wir mit... mit dem Grundlage mal diskutieren mit den...
Wir haben noch die Nachzerfallswärme, das ist eigentlich das Hauptproblem, was wir gerade haben in Japan, das sollten wir noch in Ruhe erläutern.
Genau.
Also man denkt sich ja, so ein Atomreaktor schaltet man aus und dann hört die Reaktion auf und dann geht die Temperatur runter auf Raumtemperaturen, das ist halt nicht der Fall, sondern selbst wenn man die Kettenreaktion komplett stoppt, dann gibt es immer noch diverse Zerfallprodukte von Uran, die da eben noch rumschwirren und die weiter zerfallen und dabei wird auch Energie frei. Und diese Energie ist ungefähr, nach dem Abschalten von einem Kernreaktor, ungefähr 7 Prozent der Leistung des Reaktors, allerdings der thermischen Leistung. Die elektrische Leistung von so einem Reaktor ist ungefähr ein Drittel der thermischen Leistung.
Wir reden hier von signifikanten Wärmeleistungen. Also so halt so die, also die, der Nachkühlbedarf für so die Fukushima-Reaktoren ist pro Reaktor noch für ziemlich lange Zeit in der Größenordnung zwischen 4 und 7 Megawatt, die halt wieder weggekühlt werden müssen.
Und da kommt dazu, dass die halt nicht nur einen Kern pro Reaktor haben, sondern dass sie die ganzen alten Brennstäbe auch nicht weggekarrt haben, sondern die dann noch...
Und die müssen halt auch gekühlt werden und zwar für diverse Jahre.
Gut, aber da kommen wir nachher drauf. Was passiert denn, wenn man es jetzt nicht kühlt? Das ist ja die Frage, die gerade Japan beherrscht. Das ist der schlimmste Fall, der bei so einem Reaktor passieren kann, wenn man den Reaktor runterfährt, also abgesehen von einer tatsächlichen Atomexplosion, die im Brüterreaktor theoretisch passieren kann. Dann ist das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, wenn man den aus schaltet, die Kühlung nicht funktioniert und man eine Kernschmelze hat. Das ist, dass es so heiß wird, dass die Brennsterbe schmelzen.
Darüber, was dann genau passiert, wie sie eine Kernschmelze aussieht und was dann in so einem Reaktor passiert.
Da können wir auch noch unseren Experten befragen.
Da reden wir jetzt mit Michael sailer. Wie schon erwähnt, Michael sailer ist Experte für Reaktorsicherheit beim Öko-Institut in Freiburg, ist gerade ein sehr gefragter Gesprächspartner. Wir hatten Glück, dass wir ihn zufällig heute für so ein bisschen mehr als eine Stunde erwischt haben. Und er will uns zwar ausführlich Rede und Antwort zu stehen.
Wir sind nicht ganz alle Fragen losgeworden, aber eigentlich fast alle.
Eigentlich fast alle. Und da sind ein paar ziemliche Kracher drin in diesem Interview, obwohl wir hinterher auch erst einmal...
Das eine war leider nicht on the Record. Da haben wir schon ausgestellt gehabt, als ich dann mal überschlagen habe. Also er hat unter anderem erzählt, wie viel Brennelemente dann auch rumliegen in Fukushima. Und dann habe ich mal überschlagen, dass das irgendwie so was wie 50 bis 100 Megawatt an Kühlleistungen wären, die man da wegkühlen muss. Und dann meinte ich, das kann doch nicht sein. So, weil das ist so die Größenordnung. Also wir hatten Atomkraftwerke, die kleiner waren in der Vergangenheit, als wie viel Wärmeleistung da jetzt weggekühlt werden muss. Da meinte er, doch, doch. So viel ist das.
Ja, den Rest haben wir einen Rekord und den gibt's jetzt hier hinter. Den gibt's jetzt hier hinter und ja, bleibt dran. Das ist wirklich sehr spannend. Wir mussten uns hinterher auch erst mal einen Augenblick erholen von dem, was wir dabei so gelernt haben. Zuerst vielleicht die Frage, was wir da in Japan sehen, ist ja sozusagen die Häufung von allem, was so schiefgehen kann in dieser Art Reaktor-Design. Oder gibt's da noch Dinge, die wir noch nicht gesehen haben unterhalb einer Kernschmelze?
Also unter der Bedingung, die wir jetzt in Japan haben, dass die Kühlung ganz oder weitgehend ausgefallen ist und die Stromversorgung nicht stabil ist, ist das meiste, was man sich denken kann, schon passiert. Nicht alle Effekte, also Dampfexplosionen gab es zum Beispiel noch nicht. Das wird halt die nächsten fünf, sechs, acht Tage zeigen, ob da noch andere Effekte auftreten. Nach den theoretischen Untersuchungen sollten die auftreten, wenn die Kühlung nicht wiederhergestellt werden kann.
Und das wäre denn was?
Also wir haben ja jetzt Wasserstoff-Explosionen gehabt. Wasserstoff setzt sich dort frei, weil das Zirkon, das silberglänzende Metall, aus dem die Hüllrohre sind, bei über 800 Grad, wenn es in Wasserdampf steht, also nachdem das Kühlwasser aus dem Reaktor rausgelaufen ist praktisch, setzt sich das in einer Reaktion um. Zirkon und Wasser gibt Zirkonoxid und Wasserstoff. Und der Wasserstoff ist ja jetzt an verschiedenen Stellen auch ausgekommen und teilweise auch explodiert. Das ist erst gebannt, wenn alles Zirkon sich umgesetzt hat.
Und dann liegt aber das Brennstoffmaterial frei?
Dann liegt der Brennstoff, das sind ja dann Tabletten. Also das Zirkon ist eigentlich gedacht, um sozusagen so eine Tablettenröhre, also ein Hüllrohr zu bilden, in dem dann wirklich Tabletten eingefüllt sind. Und das heißt, ich habe zwei Sachen. Das eine ist, dass es natürlich frei liegt, also die Einschließungswirkung vom Zirkon nicht mehr da ist. Aber dadurch, dass es Tabletten sind, habe ich da natürlich auch keine mechanische Stabilität mehr von der Einheit. Das heißt, es kann sich alles dann irgendwo hinlegen, wenn die Zirkon-Hüllrohre weg sind.
Und das gilt sowohl für den Reaktor als auch für die Abklingbecken?
Das gilt für die Brennelemente in den Abklingbecken. Das gilt auch für die Brennelemente im Reaktor. In den Abklingbecken kommt noch eine andere Geschichte dazu, die offensichtlich auch schon gelaufen ist, mindestens in Block 4. Die Brennelemente stehen ja normal unter Wasser und dann habe ich irgendwelche Oberflächentemperaturen an den Hüllerohren in der Preisklasse von 30, 40 Grad. Also bis 60 ist es normalerweise akzeptabel und für Notfälle bis 80. Aber das geht eigentlich nur, wenn die voll im Wasser stehen. Und wenn die nicht mehr im Wasser stehen und an der allgemeinen Atmosphäre sind, also sprich Sauerstoff genügend da ist, dann kann das Zirkon, wenn sich dann überhitzt, auch selbst entzünden. Das ist ähnlich wie Magnesium oder Aluminium bei höheren Temperaturen.
Zirkoniumpulver wurde zum Beispiel auch verwendet oder wurde früher verwendet in Blitzlampen. Also für, wo man normalerweise Fotoblitze mit Magnesium befüllt hat, hat man dann Zirkonenpulver genommen, weil es rauchlos brennt.
Na warum nimmt man überhaupt Zirkonen? Das liegt doch in der Eigenschaft der Kerne.
Also da hat man ganz wenige Reaktoren, bei denen man auch Stahl als Hüllerohr genommen hat. Aber Zirkonen hat zufällig, neutronenphysikalisch die Eigenschaft, dass es sehr wenig stört in dem ganzen Kanspaltungsprozess, was da läuft. Man muss ja da immer sehr genau gucken, wie die Neutronenbilanz stimmt und zwar nicht nur über den Kern, sondern in jeder einzelnen Teilzone des Kerns. Und da ist halt ein Hüllerohrmaterial schön, das da praktisch keinen Anfluss hat.
Eine Sache, wo gerade noch die Analysen auseinandergehen, ist, wenn wir jetzt außen, außerhalb des Reaktors, eine Knallgasexplosion sehen, ist das ein Beweis dafür, dass das containment geborsten ist oder nicht?
Nee, es ist erstmal ein Beweis dafür, dass, weil diese Zirkonenwasserstoffreaktionen, die ich vorhin geschildert hab, die läuft erst so ab 800 Grad richtig. Das ist erstmal ein Beweis dafür, dass in dem ungekühlten Reaktorkan die Temperatur 800 Grad überschritten ist. Deswegen ist ja dann auch die Diskussion losgegangen, ob wir schon bei der Kernschmelze sind. Aber es war jetzt einfach ein Indiz, man ist schon deutlich.
Mindestens bei 800 Grad.
Und das heißt aber auch, dass das Wasser drum herum weg ist, oder?
Ja, das geht nur, wenn das Wasser drum herum weg ist. Also wobei man sich das nicht so vorstellen muss, Wasser weg, sondern es fängt ja dort an, wo die Wasserbedeckung nicht mehr ist. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass ein Brennelement, das sind ja so in der Preisklasse 5 Meter lang, dass das an den Füßen noch im Wasser steht, aber am Kopf längst sich aufheizen, am Aufheizen ist, wo der Wasserspiegel gesunken ist. Und dann passiert das oben schon mit der Reaktion und das ist oben dann viel heißer als unten.
Und das heißt, der Wasserstoff sammelt sich dann erst mal im eigentlichen Reaktordruckkörper und wie kommt er von da ans containment?
Also der sammelt sich im eigentlichen Reaktordruckbehälter und möglicherweise in anschließenden Leitungen, weil die sind ja vom Sicherheitskonzept her bei der Vorgeschichte, die wir in Japan haben, werden die eigentlich ein geschlossenes System. Da sind also noch Ventile zugefallen und solche Dinge, die das dann abschließen. Das heißt, der Wasserstoff sammelt sich erstmal oben am Druckbehälter, weil er jetzt leichteste Gas ist, was damit unterwegs ist. Und da gibt es Möglichkeiten, da eine Gasentlastung oder Druckentlastung zu machen. Das hat man in Herresburg, also bei dem Unfall 1979 gelernt, dass man aufpassen muss, dass da nicht zu viel Wasserstoff ist. Das heißt, es gibt Leitungen, die extra nach außen ins Reaktorgebäude oder über Dach führen. Da sind wir uns unter den Experten jetzt nicht ganz sicher, wie das konkret in Japan war, bei denen man den Wasserstoff abblasen kann.
Also nicht mal ins containment, sondern direkt aus dem Reaktorbehälter übers containment drüber ins Dach.
Ja.
Das ist jetzt aber was anderes als das Druckablassen, was die Japaner gemacht haben, oder nicht?
Das macht man mehr oder weniger mit dem gleichen System. Das heißt, es kann mal die Absicht sein bei einer Druckablasssituation, dass man den Druck ablassen will. Und dann käme, wenn jetzt kein Wasserstoff da ist, praktisch nur Wasserdampf raus. Oder man hat eben in dem Gasgemisch über dem Reaktorkern zwischen den heißen Brennelementen sowohl Wasser als auch, also Wasserdampf als auch Wasserstoff. Und dann lässt man natürlich beides ab.
Das heißt also, dass die Explosion jetzt gerade bei dem ersten Block, wo der Dach komplett weggeflogen ist, und es auch in einer sehr schnellen Explosion war, was ja auf sich eine Wasserstoff-Explosion war. Das heißt also, es kann sein, dass das nicht mal durchs containment ins Dach gegangen ist, sondern direkt vom Reaktor ins Dach geleitet wurde.
Das kann gut sein. Man muss ja bei den Bedingungen dann aber auch nochmal überlegen, dass keiner genau weiß, ob die Systeme im gleichen Zustand sind. Das heißt, es kann auch sein, dass nicht vorgesehene Leckagen dann dazu führen. Und da hängt es ja dann immer davon ab, in welchem Raum ist die Leitung, wo das Leck ist, wie breitet sich das dann weiter aus. Und man muss auch nochmal überlegen, die Brennelemente, die in dem Lagerbecken sind. Und die Lagerbecken sind bei allen Reaktoren in Fukushima sozusagen im obersten Stockwerk des Reaktorgebäudes.
Direkt unterm Dach.
Direkt unterm Dach, praktisch neben dem oberen Teil des Reaktors. Und bei den Brennelementen kann sich auch Ratiolysegas bilden. Wenn jetzt seit Freitag kein Strom mehr da war, um das Ratiolysegas zu entfernen mit den üblichen Systemen, kann es auch da eine Ansammlung gegeben haben. Also es gibt verschiedene Ursachen, keiner weiß.
Dass wir beim Post-Mortem irgendwie sich zurechtdeuten können.
Wenn noch genügend analysierbare Zustellenspuren da sind.
Ist das ein anderes Kühlsystem für dieses abklingenden Benken wie für den Reaktor? Oder also wenn man das eine mit Notstrom versorgt, ist das andere nicht automatisch mitversorgt?
Also das ist bei jedem Reaktor sehr unterschiedlich konstruiert. Und zwar einfach deswegen, weil die meisten Experten, die mal Kernkraftwerke ausgelegt haben, immer gesagt haben, das Kühlproblem im Reaktor ist größer als bei dem Lagerbecken. Das können wir also ein Stück weit nachrangig behandeln. Was dann in manchen Kernkraftwerken, auch in Deutschland, so konstruiert ist, dass praktisch die Notkühlung und die Beckenkühlung zum Teil auf gleiche Systeme zurückgreift und dann halt Vorrangschaltungen sind, die im Notfall sagen, Reaktor kühlen. Es gibt auch Kernkraftwerke und das wissen wir jetzt nicht, wie das in Japan war, die da ein ziemlich getrenntes System haben, aber kein vollständiges. Man muss sich an der Stelle auch nochmal klar machen, das sind ja alles Kühlsysteme, die Wasser befördern, das mit der Radioaktivität an Brennelementen direkt in Verbindung kommt, im Normalbetrieb schon.
Auch beim Reaktor?
Beim Reaktor, klar.
Die Turbine wird mit radioaktivem Dampf betrieben?
Beim Sido-Wasserreaktor ist es so, dass der radioaktive Dampf direkt auf die Turbine geht. Beim Druckwasserreaktor, der hat ja zwei Kreisläufe.
Noch ein Wärmetauscher dazwischen.
Ein Wärmetauscher. Und jetzt wieder Stichwort Wärmetauscher. Ich muss bei diesem Wärmeabführsystem, jetzt egal, ob das ein Beckenkühlsystem ist oder ein Kühlsystem für einen abgeschalteten Reaktor oder auch ein Notkühlsystem, brauche ich, um zu vermeiden, dass Radioaktivität rauskommt, auch immer gestaffelte Wärmetauscher. Und da hat man üblicherweise sogar zwei. Das heißt, ich habe eigentlich drei Systeme hintereinander über zwei Wärmetauscher aneinander gekoppelt.
Die wollt ihr eigenen Pumpen brauchen?
Die ihre eigenen Pumpen brauchen, die ihr eigenes Wasser brauchen. Jeder der Systeme geht natürlich nur, wenn das Wasser drin ist. Und damit habe ich mit den Pumpen sofort wieder die Frage, was hier in Japan schiefgegangen ist, ist die Stromversorgung. Geht die ganze sogenannte Nachkühlkette? Geht nicht mehr, wenn ich nicht den Strom habe, um diese Pumpen für alle drei Stufen zu bewegen. Wenn eine Stufe schon nicht mehr geht, dann geht die Kette nicht mehr.
Also was man ja auch, wo man keine richtige Vorstellung hat, ist, wie viel Energie braucht man eigentlich, um diese Pumpen zu betreiben? Im Normalfall und im Notfall. Also wie viel Strom muss man denn da jetzt rankauen, an so ein Kraftwerk, um das noch kühlen zu können?
Also das hängt jetzt auch wieder von ab, wie die Sicherheitssysteme sind, welche Pumpen, mit welcher Leistung ich habe. Das sind normalerweise mehrere Megawatt in Kraftwerk, die ich also als Notsysteme betreiben muss.
Um das Wasser umzuwälzen.
Da sind mehrere Dinge dabei. Also ein zentraler Teil sind eine ganze Reihe von Pumpen, die Wasser, also diese gerade beschriebenen Nachkühlkete zum Beispiel für einen Notfall oder auch Einspeisepumpen, wo man aus Wasser vorräte und dann versucht, wenn ein Leck ist, das zu ergänzen. Es sind aber auch große Ventilatoren, weil ein Kernkraftwerk ja gegen die Freisetzung im normal betrieben gestaffeltes Unterdruckhaltesystem hat. Das heißt, ich muss durch alle Räume, die wegen der Radioaktivität spannend sind, im Kernkraftwerk über eine gestaffelte Unterdruckhaltung eine Dichtheit erzeugen. Also dass eine Undichtheit immer in den Raum mit der größeren Radioaktivität geht. Die hängen auch am Notstrom, aber die sind ja auch ausgefallen. Deswegen konnte man sich eigentlich schon vor einer Woche in Fukushima nicht darauf verlassen, dass die üblichen Dichtheitssachen bestehen, weil die eben aktiv durch Ventilatoren, die auch mit hohen Leistungen und hohem Leistungsbedarf betrieben wird und nicht alleine durch jetzt passiv absolut lichte Wände oder sowas.
Das heißt also, ist denn dieses containment, also sozusagen die, die, die, die, nach dem Reaktor die nächste Matroschka-Hülle, ist die auch so betrieben, also dass die aktiven Unterdruck braucht oder ist die eigentlich als passiv mit Lippendichtung und so?
Also das containment ist, das hat ja in Fukushima, bei den Reaktoren, die haben ein bisschen unterschiedliche, je nachdem welcher Blocks ist, weil es unterschiedliche Herstellungsgenerationen sind. Aber das Grundprinzip ist immer, dass es eine geschlossene Stahlhülle ist. Das heißt, wenn ich von innen im containment gucke, gucke ich überall auf eine Stahlwand oder eine Stahlleine. Das heißt, es hängt an der Dichtheit der Schweißnähte. Ich habe trotzdem im Normalbetrieb dort einen Unterdruck gegenüber dem Reaktorgebäude aus der beschriebenen Unterdruckhaltung her. Ich habe aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich einen Kühlmittelverluststörfall habe, also es reißt mir eine Reaktorleitung ab und dann kriege ich im containment einen Überdruck. Das ist natürlich auch erstmal dann ausgelegt, den maximal denkbaren Überdruck an der Stelle dann noch auszuhalten.
Von dem, was gerade der Ingenieur meinte, dass sie den offenbar 50 Prozent unterdimensioniert hatten.
Das ist jetzt eine zusätzliche Diskussion, ob die Auslegung dann stimmt. Und ich meine, das muss man ja jetzt nach den Ereignissen in Fukushima auf jeden Fall überall fragen, ist eigentlich das, was ins Design als maximal denkbare Größe, jetzt in dem Fall Druck, in anderen Fällen Volumen oder Temperatur oder Beschleunigung durch ein Erdbeben oder so, das muss ich mir jetzt an allen Stellen fragen, war das wirklich das maximal Denkbare?
Ich wundere mich so ein bisschen, wenn wir auf der einen Seite sagen, das containment muss den maximal denkbaren Druck aushalten, auf der anderen Seite haben wir ein System zum Druck ablassen, ist das nicht ein Widerspruch?
Also das sind zwei Ebenen sozusagen so eine Art Defense in Depth. Also man muss immer aufpassen, dieser schöne Spruch GAU, den wir in Fachkreisen heute nicht mehr verwenden, heißt ja größter anzunehmender Unfall und nicht größter vorkommender Unfall. Das heißt, es ist eine Designgrundlage. Heutzagen war Auslegungsstörfall dazu oder Design Base Accident, wenn wir in den USA sind. Das heißt, man geht da vom Vorgehen erst mal hin und sagt, zum Beispiel maximal kann eine Rohrleitung reisen mit dem und dem Durchmesser und dem und dem Wasserinventar und Energieinventar dahinter. Und da rechne ich mir dann aus, was der maximal auftretende Druck in so einer Situation ist. Und dann sage ich, mein containment muss das mit 30 Prozent Sicherheitszuschlag halten. Wenn jetzt die erste Annahme falsch ist, dann ist natürlich die ganze Folge auch falsch.
Und dafür hat man dann die Möglichkeit, dann das containment doch noch zu wenden, wenn es nicht ist.
Ja, und das war, was ich jetzt gerade beschrieben habe, war die Sicherheitsebene Auslegungsstörfall. Und nachdem man spätestens nach Tschernobyl, aber teilweise schon nach Herisburg 1979 verstanden hat, dass es manchmal doch schlimmer kommt, als der Auslegungsstörfall, hat man dann diese zusätzliche Ebene eingeführt, haben wir noch Maßnahmen, wenn es schief geht. Und daher kommen diese Druckentlastungsleitungen, die da in Fukushima auch da waren.
Also das heißt, im Grunde, wenn wir in den Nachrichten hören von einem Atomkraftwerk, dass sie Druck abgelassen haben, dann ist schon Arsch auf Grunde.
Also wenn die jetzt nicht normal, es gibt auch ein paar Sachen, wo die bei Störungen Druck ablassen, dann kann das sogar noch nicht mal ein Störfall sein. Es gibt aber, wenn man jetzt hört, in so einer ähnlichen Situation wie in Fukushima, dass die Druck ablassen, dann ist das so eine, Experten-Slang-Notfall-Maßnahme, die halt schon vorgeplant war, weil man das in Harrisburg gelernt hat.
Also das war so der Punkt, wo die Nachrichten meine vollständige Aufmerksamkeit hatten, als Greenpeace meinte, ja das mit dem Druck ablassen wäre jetzt gerade eine gute Idee.
Ja, das ist irgendwie, da haben wir angefangen uns Sorgen zu machen, dass Greenpeace meint, das hätten wir auch gemacht.
Jetzt wird es nicht mehr so richtig schön, ne?
Ja, also man muss sich noch mal klar machen, als die Nachrichtenlage überhaupt was erzählt hat, waren wir schon jenseits der Störfallebene. Also da waren wir schon in dieser Ebene, wo nur noch Notfallmaßnahmen gibt. Also die bewegen sich in Japan praktisch seit, sagen wir mal zwei Stunden nach dem Erdbeben und zwei Stunden nach dem Tsunami am Standort bewegen, die sich jenseits der Auslegung. Also weil viele Leute denken ja immer noch, wieso haben die solche primitiven Mittel, was man da jetzt so alles hört, mal Seewasserkühlung, mal Wasserschmeißen und so, die haben, also für Kontrolle auf der Anlage gibt es die drei Stufen. Normalbetrieb, gestörter Betrieb, wo aber noch kein richtiger Störfall ist und Störfall einschließlich Beherrschung durch Sicherheitssysteme, die mehrfach da sind und wenn die Mindestzahl geht, geht's. Und die sind seit zwei Stunden nach dem Ereignis, sind die außerhalb dieser Ebene und deswegen passieren da lauter Sachen, die nur noch Notfall sind.
Also die improvisieren im Wesentlichen. Also ich meine, das oder gibt es für so eine, für so eine Szenarien, gibt es da, ja, sag mal, Manuals oder so.
Also wir haben, wir haben in Deutschland die letzten fünf Jahre eine harte Fachdebatte darüber, ob man sogenanntes Sam-Cheese macht, Severexistent-Management-Guides. Und die gibt es bei manchen Kernkraftwerken weltweit, die gibt es bei anderen nicht. Also das sind eigentlich so Art Handbücher, wo drin steht, wenn dir jetzt alles das weggefallen ist, hast du ungefähr noch folgende drei Möglichkeiten. Und dann probier erst mal, an die Stelle Strom zu bringen, oder probier mal, ob du mit einer Feuerlöschpumpe, die mobil ist, an den und den Stutzen gehen kannst, weil da kannst du das Wasser am besten einspeisen, in dem Fall des Falles. Also solche Dinge. Weil, wenn man sich das ad hoc überlegen muss, dann ist es spannend. Wir haben es bisher in Deutschland nicht vorgeschrieben, aber ich glaube, dass das so ein Mindesteffekt jetzt nach Fukushima für deutsche Kernkraftwerke sein wird, dass man das überall machen muss.
Freiwillig haben die das noch nicht?
Also es gibt eine lange Debatte. Also wir haben bei uns, sagen die Betreiber, man muss diese Ebene jenseits der Störfälle nicht wirklich betrachten. Und deswegen gab es auch die Auseinandersetzung, dass man, ob es jetzt, ob die Behörden rechtlich durchsetzen können, dass solche San-G's gebaut werden oder nicht.
Also ich meine, ich finde es insofern spannend, weil wenn man sich diese Atomtechnologie anguckt, dann scheint es auf den ersten Blick erst mal relativ straightforward. So hat man so einen Reaktor, der ist warm, da gibt es Dampf. Und wenn man den nicht mehr warm will, dann fährt man halt die Steuerstäbe rein. Und dann hört es auf warm zu sein. Aber wenn man dann mal ein bisschen genauer hinguckt, dann ist das ja nicht so. Dann ist ja eben gerade auch die Neutronenphysik dahinter ja doch sehr viel komplexer. Also eine der Sachen, die wir halt bei der Vorbereitung gesehen haben, war ja zum Beispiel dieser Effekt mit dem Xenon-135-Aufbau, der halt in unserem Reaktor passiert. Also dass sich da einfach durch die chemischen und radiologischen Reaktionen Stoffe bilden, die halt über die Zeiten einen Einfluss auf diesen Reaktor haben. Oder sollte man noch eigentlich denken, dass man so was mal in so ein Handbuch für Reaktorfahrer oder so reintut?
Also solche Sachen sind sowieso, die gehören in den Grundkurs für einen Reaktorfahrer-Lehrling.
Also für den Normalbetrieb eben?
Nee, überhaupt das alles zu kennen gehört in den Grundkurs. Aber da kann man noch lange nicht Reaktorfahrer werden. Auch wenn man das gut kennt, da muss man noch mehr können. Und es gehört natürlich auch in die Auslegung der Kerne rein. Also es gibt ja spezielle Arbeitsgruppen bei den Betreibern, die jeden einzelnen Reaktorkern auslegen. Mit Kern ist jetzt nicht gemeint, ich geh mal in Brunsbüttel hin und schreib auf, wie die nächsten 30 Jahre die Brennelemente aussehen, sondern wirklich die Brennelemente, die nächstes Jahr eingesetzt werden, die haben eine ganz konkrete Lebensgeschichte. Da ist halt in jedem Brennelement unterschiedlich stark der Brennstoff abgebrannt, das ist es eine. Es ist unterschiedliche Konzentration an Brennstoff, die noch drin ist. Das heißt, wie viel Material haben die Neutronen eigentlich zum Spalten? Oder wie wirksam ist auch ein Neutron? Das kann man sich ja leicht vorstellen. Hängt von der Dichte, von dem spaltbaren Material im entsprechenden Volumen ab. Es ist aber auch so, dadurch, dass fast alle Stoffe in irgendeiner Weise Neutronen absorbieren oder manchmal auch noch komplexer damit umgehen, muss ich auch die Geschichte, was sich an Spaltprodukten aufgebaut hat, durchziehen. Und das hängt wieder jetzt nicht einfach davon ab, wie lange ist im Reaktor gestanden, sondern das ist, wenn ich jetzt ein Jahr voll straight gefahren bin, ist das was anderes. Also habe ich eine andere Anzahl und Menge von Spaltprodukten, als wenn zum Beispiel das zwei Monate stillgestanden ist zwischendrin, weil viele der Spaltprodukte, die sich da auf die Neutronen auswirken, sind eigentlich solche, die radioaktiv sind und relativ kurzlebig. Auch das Xenon, über das wir gerade kurz gesprochen haben.
Das dauert ja nur ein paar Stunden, ja?
Ja, das hat nur ein paar Stunden Halbwertszeit. Und jetzt ist es ja so, wenn so ein Isotop da ist und nimmt relativ viel Neutronen weg, ist also eher ein Neutronengift, und das verschwindet wieder, dann habe ich ja am Anfang eine Situation, bei der ich den Reaktor so steuern muss, dass ein Überfluss, also nicht Überfluss ist falsch, aber mehr Neutronen produziert, weil da eine ganze Menge absorbiert wird, anstatt dass es Kernspaltung macht. Wenn sich aber dann so ein Isotop sich wieder abgebaut hat, dann wird ja weniger absorbiert. Das heißt, das muss ich dann nachfahren. Und da ist ein physikalischer Vorteil dabei, nämlich der, dass relativ viel dieser Effekte selbstrückkoppelnd sind. Und deswegen muss ich es nicht wirklich nachfahren in dem Sinn, dass ich den Reaktor von Hand steuern muss. Also das sind viele Sachen, die dazu führen, dass es über negative Rückkopplung dann doch sozusagen auf der Kennlinie bleibt. Ich muss aber beim Festlegen der konkreten Konfiguration davor mir sehr klar sein, dass die Kernkonfiguration auch in der Lage ist, über diese negativen Rückkopplungsprozesse wirklich auf einer Kennlinie zu fahren. Also das Problem...
Also in Tschernobyl war ja wohl, dass sie genau dieses langsam wieder runterfahren, nachdem der Xenon ein Bild weggebrannt war, dass sie das nicht hinbekommen haben. Also einer der auslösenden Faktoren.
Also Tschernobyl hat ja ein Stück andere Kernphysik im Kern gehabt. Das heißt, die haben nicht so viele negative Rückkopplungsprozesse gehabt, sondern die hatten auch verschiedene kernphysikalische Dinge, die eine positive Rückkopplung hatten. Das heißt, wenn es passiert, läuft es nach oben. Und was die eigentlich gemacht haben, in dem was sie jetzt gerade gemeint war, die haben den Kern, der war in einem neutronphysikalischen oder insgesamt kernphysikalischen Zustand, bei dem man hätte gar nicht fahren dürfen, weil zu viele positive Rückkopplungen drin waren. Und das hat dort auch zu der Explosion, die ja dort eine Nuklearexplosion, also eine durchgehende Kettenreaktion war, also jetzt nicht Wasserstoff oder so, wie in Fukushima, das war das Problem. Und jetzt andersrum, die Leute bei jedem Reaktor, die müssen davor immer ausrechnen, ich habe Brennelement Nummer 1 bis 150 werden nächstes Mal wieder verwendet. Brennelement 1 war eins, das hat jetzt zwei Jahre am Rand außen gestanden, also ich vereinfache es ein bisschen an der Stelle, das ist noch komplexer. Hat also wenig Kernspaltung mitgekriegt, weil am Rand des Reaktors ist ja der Neutronenverlust größer und damit habe ich weniger Kernspaltung. Brennelement 2 hat jetzt ein Jahr hinter sich in der Mitte, ziemlich in der Mitte des Reaktors, also viel Kernspaltung. Die haben jetzt unterschiedlichen Spaltstoffgehalt, haben unterschiedliche Spaltproduktmengen und teilweise auch ein bisschen von der Zusammensetzung anders und damit wieder völlig unterschiedliches Neutronenphysikalisches Verhalten. Und da muss ich, wenn ich jetzt sage, ein Drittel der Stäbe ist alt, die nehme ich raus und zwei Drittel setze ich wieder ein und außerdem setze ich ein Drittel neue Stäbe ein. Das passiert ja jedes Jahr in dem Prinzip. Da muss ich ganz genau ausrechnen, welches Brennelement kann ich wo im Kern reinstellen?
Kann man so ein, also wenn ich jetzt so ein Brennelement auf dem Parkplatz finde, kann ich dem ansehen, was da drin ist? Oder kann ich das irgendwie messen? Oder kann ich das nur wissen, weil ich beobachtet habe, wo es eingesetzt war?
Also eine ganz brutale Aussage jetzt an der Stelle, man kann sich eine Stunde nebendran stellen, wenn man da nicht tot ist und innerlich verblutet war, ist das ein frisches Brennelement.
Aber weitergehende Sachen kann man nicht sehen?
Nein, in der Praxis verfolgen die ja... Also so ein Brennelement, wenn es dann kein frisches mehr ist, ist ja immer an einer bestimmten Position im Kern. Und wenn es ausgebaut wird, ist es mal ausgebaut und wird dann wieder an eine bestimmte Position im Kern eingebaut. Das heißt, ich kann erstens über Modellrechnungen, da sind die Rechenprogramme sehr exakt, kann ich das genau nachvollziehen. Und so wird auch die Planung fürs jeweils nächste Jahr gemacht, dass man also mit der Geschichte, die man auf jedem Brennelement hat, dann auch durchspielt, wo kann man das Brennelement bei der nächsten Periode überhaupt hinstellen. Weil da hab ich ja nur...
Worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, ob es da eine Buchhaltung braucht oder ob ich sozusagen das Element angucken kann und sagen kann, also den stellen wir die beide hinten hin.
Nein, das Brennelement hat eine ganz klare Nummer und es hat eine ganz klare Buchhaltung aus vielen anderen Gründen, aber auch aus dem Grund, dass ich die Geschichte von dem Brennelement ab dem ersten Einsatz voll dokumentiert haben muss, damit ich in der Modellrechnung so eine Zusammensetzung kriege. Ich hab natürlich auch, wenn ich jetzt feinere, keine physikalischen Messungen nehme, kann ich über Spektrum von Strahlung und ein paar andere Sachen, nicht den Zustand des Brennelements nachmessen, aber ich kann überprüfen, ob die Effekte, die ich wirklich messen kann, ob die bei dem Modell da wären.
Ist denn diese Zusammensetzung, spielt die denn jetzt in Fukushima eine Rolle für die Frage, die zum Beispiel immer wieder gestellt wird, wenn es jetzt eine Kernschmelze gibt, ist das, was da unten rausläuft, in der Lage, eine Kettenreaktion von sich aus aufrechtzuerhalten?
Also dafür spielt das schon eine zentrale Rolle. Also was ist die Geschichte von jedem einzelnen Brennelement? Es spielt natürlich auch, wenn eine Kernschmelze ist oder wenn man sich vorstellt, dass die Hüllrohre weg sind, dann hat man ja eher einen Haufen von Brennstofftabletten als noch Brennelemente, als eine ganz geometrische Aufstellung. Da spielt das schon eine starke Rolle. Manche von den Konfigurationen können wieder kritisch werden, wenn reines Wasser als Moderator zwischen Reihen läuft. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum die Vorsichtshalber jetzt bei der Meerwasseraktion immer Boa mit dazu getan haben.
Also Boa ist halt ein Neutronengift und?
Ja, Boa ist einer der Stoffe, die ganz stark Neutronen rausnehmen. Und Boa ist gleichzeitig von der Chemie her ein leicht löslicher Stoff. Deswegen Boasäure. Das heißt, der ist technisch gut handhabbar und ist gleichzeitig ein ziemlich starkes Neutronengift. Und damit kann ich halt gegen kompensieren. Das Wasser würde als Moderator ja eine Kettenreaktion wieder anstoßen, wenn die Brennstoffkonfiguration dazu passt. Und wenn die Brennstoffkonfiguration passt und das Wasser zusammen dann Kettenreaktion machen würde, hätten wir ja wieder massiv zusätzlichen Energieeintrag und explosive Effekte.
Das heißt also eigentlich ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dann zu einer Kettenreaktion kommt in, sagen wir an dem Abklingbecken, wo die Brennstäbe oben abbrennen und dann ins Wasser fallen größer, als wenn es tatsächlich zu einer Kernschmelze kommt, wo alles zusammenfließt oder ist das falsch?
Das hängt vom Einzelfall ab. Also deswegen muss man bei Störfallanalysen praktisch vorausdenken, wie kann es auch wohl mit dem Wasser sein, wie kann es mit dem Strukturmaterial sein, wie kann es mit den Brennelementen sein. Und dann durchrechnen, ist da eine kritische, also nuklearkritische Konfiguration möglich, bei der die Kettenreaktion wieder losgeht? Oder ist es nicht möglich, vorsichtshalber, also arbeiten wir mit extrem hohen Sicherheitszuschlägen bei den Rechnungen. Also man geht da auf die sichere Seite und deswegen hat man praktisch immer Neutronengifte mit. Also wenn man jetzt das Brennelementlager als konkretes Beispiel nimmt, das darf nicht mit rein Wasser befüllt sein.
Okay.
Und deswegen ist da normalerweise entweder borriertes Wasser drin, also das Kühlwasser ist borriert schon im Normalbetrieb, oder die, das sind ja so, man könnte es sich wie Sprudelkisten vorstellen, also so Lagergeställe, in denen jedes einzelne Brennelement in ein einzelnes Fach kommt. Da sind oft die Wände von dem nicht aus normalem Stahl, sondern aus borriertem Stahl gemacht. Also jetzt auch nicht wegen der chemischen Legierung, sondern wegen der Neutronengiftwirkung. Und das ist dann auch vorausgerechnet, wie viel Bohrgehalt der Stahl haben muss zum Beispiel.
Und wenn man jetzt so einen Reaktorkern schmilzt, dann schmelzen ja die Steuerstäbe mit. Dann hätte man ja sozusagen, also das kann man eigentlich...
Na tun sie das? Das ist ja eine der Fragen, die wir haben. Also gebildet sich am Ende so ein Orangenlumpen unten oder eine Pfütze, sag ich mal. Oder ist der Rest schmilzt ja mit und das Bohr aus dem Stahlgerüst ist auch unten mit drin?
Also erstmal Pfütze. Das Brennstoffgewicht in dem ersten Reaktor in Fukushima ist irgendwas um die 60 Tonnen in den anderen Reaktoren. Die sind ja etwas größer, 90 Tonnen.
Also in sich.
Pfütze mit 90 Tonnen ist ein bisschen schwierig vorstellbar.
Zumal auch noch der Rest von dem Reaktor mit schmilzt.
Aber man muss sich nochmal die Temperaturverhältnisse klar machen. Der Brennstoff als solcher schmilzt bei deutlich über 2000 Grad erst. Also das ist eine relativ feste Geschichte gegen Schmelzen. Das heißt aber andersrum, wenn der schmilzt und hat seine 2200 oder 2400 Grad, dann schmilzt der alles auf, was er trifft. Das heißt die Frage, ob da jetzt ein Steuerelement mit schmilzt, natürlich, weil es eine viel niedrigeren Schmelztemperatur hat oder...
Aber sind die da nicht schon vorher geschmolzen und bilden separat?
Das kann alles sein. Also wir müssen ja damit rechnen und das macht die Situation komplex, aber trotzdem ein Stück weit vorhersehbar. Die eigentliche Schmelze schmilzt erst dann. Wenn aber alle Strukturmaterialien weg sind, ist ja vielleicht eher ein Brennstoff-Tablettenhaufen unten im Reaktordruckbehälter, lang bevor die selbst geschmolzen sind. Es kommt aber genauso, wie gerade gesagt, können natürlich andere Materialien, solange sie jetzt nicht gemischt sind, wenn die Stahl schmilzt bei 14-1500 Grad. Steuerstäbe habe ich jetzt gerade nicht im Kopf. Also einzelne Sachen könnten da schon geschmolzen sein. Es kann auch sein, sobald da irgendwo Sauerstoff ist, dass da Teile abbrennen, was brennbar ist. Also insofern kann man jetzt nicht sagen, ich habe genau die Mischung da. Ich muss sowohl davon ausgehen, dass vielleicht wirklich nur der Kern da geschmolzen liegt, also relativ konzentriert da ist, weil das für bestimmte Betrachtungen das Übelste ist. Oder ich muss von ausgehen, dass alles, was an Einbauten, Steuerstäbe, da gibt es ja auch viele Halter und so, das Ganze wird ja über solche Fächer und Bodenplatten und Abstandshalter und sonst was gehalten, dass das dann irgendwie mit in der Schmelze ist. Und das ist in anderen Fällen wieder ein Problem. Und das heißt, ich habe einfach...
Das heißt also, die Vorhersage ist extrem schwierig, wird da eigentlich tatsächlich...
Es geht keine Vorhersage mehr. Ich meine, wir haben ganz... Deswegen können sowohl ich wie andere Experten überhaupt kommentieren, wo wir sind, von der Ferne aus. Wir haben für den Reaktortyp und für die anderen üblichen Reaktortypen die letzten 20 Jahre extrem viele Studien gemacht. Was passiert, wenn? Also sind Kernschmelzen durchgerechnet worden, sind auch unterschiedliche von den chemischen Prozessen oder explosiven Prozessen, die ich jetzt angedeutet habe, durchgerechnet worden. Aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, es passiert genau der Fall. Weil man eben wegen den denkbaren völlig unterschiedlichen Mischungen bei völlig unterschiedlichen Zusammensetzungen im konkreten Fall sein kann.
Wie vertrauenswürdig sind denn diese Berechnungen? Also ich als Hacker kenne das halt so. Ich überlege mir zwar vorher, was ich erwarte, aber das ist eher, also ich will nicht sagen die Ausnahme, aber das ist durchaus häufig, dass es ganz anders kommt. Und da, das kann man ja schlecht testen, wie sich so ein Reaktor verhält, wenn es eine Kernschmelze gibt. Wie macht man denn das?
Also, ich glaube, da ist ein Kernreaktor einfacher als ein Computerprogramm oder eine Hardware, würde ich mal klar sagen. Weil man kennt die Physik, das heißt, die eine Frage, wie viel Wärme wird produziert, die ist ziemlich klar zu beantworten. Ist ja schon mal ein wichtiges Eingangsdatum für das Verhalten. Man kennt auch die Ausgangsstoffzusammensetzung. Also, ich weiß, da sind 60 Tonnen Uranoxid drin. Ich weiß, da sind so und so viele Tonnen Zirkon als Hülrormaterial von den Brennelementen drin. Ich weiß, so und so viel Stahl ist drin. So und so viel Wasser ist drin. Und beim Wasser muss ich mal die Frage stellen, ist es im Fall des Falles drin oder draußen. Also, ich habe da relativ wenig Variationsmöglichkeiten. Dann kommen eben die Varianten, die dann sagen, es entsteht Wasserstoff und der sprengt sich einen Weg frei. Oder es entsteht Überdruck durchs Verdampfen vom Wasser und Verdampfen aus dem Kern und entstandenen Wasserstoff. Also, die Dinge, die kann man dann durch verschiedene Szenarien auffangen. Das ist jetzt nicht genau ein Strich, sondern es ist eine Bandbreite durch Szenarien. Aber die ist relativ klar, was man nicht genau weiß, also was man nie ausschließen kann, dass noch ein zusätzlicher physikalischer oder chemischer Effekt auftaucht. Aber es sind viele von den Effekten erkannt worden. Es sind auch erkannt worden durch Forschungen.
Oder durch Unfälle. Also Mayak zum Beispiel war ja auch so ein Ding, wo sie...
Mayak war aber eine ganz andere Technik. Also aus Mayak kann man viel lernen über die Ausbreitung, aber wenig übers Verhalten von Brennstoff.
Oder war es doch so, dass es am Ende eine chemische Explosion war, wo die Fortsetzung der Spaltung dazu geführt hat, dass sie da Elementenkombinationen hatten, die am Ende eine explosive Mischung ergaben.
Ja, aber Mayak war kein Reaktor. Mayak war eine Lagerung mit Wiederaufarbeitungsabfällen, wo auch kein Brennstoff mit drin ist. Und das ist jetzt wiederum, das kann man auch modellieren, aber das ist eine völlig andere Anlage. Also kann ich für die Kanne jetzt nichts rausholen.
Ein Beispiel für die Komplexität der Prozesse, die man da modellieren muss.
Ja, ja. Und deswegen sind ja die Experten, die ich jetzt für fachlich gebildet halt, es gibt ja auch manche, die erzählen, nach Wärme hört nach 30 Stunden auf und haben einen Leerstuhl für Reaktortechnik. Experten, die ich für gebildet halt, und es sind viele, die jetzt kommentieren, die wissen halt, was ist klar in dem Sinn, wie ich es auch vorhin erzählt habe, und was sind die Variationsmöglichkeiten. Und dann hat man halt im Hinterkopf noch so ein bestimmtes Ohr für mögliche Effekte, die man noch nicht kennt oder nicht vorausgedacht hat. Aber was in Fukushima bisher passiert, ist alles genau in der Bandbreite, was die Studien ergeben.
Und diese, also eine Frage bewegt mich noch. In Deutschland war es ja so, weil wir auch kein Endlager haben, ja auch sehr viel an den Kraftwerken selbst gelagert wurde. Also praktisch genau dasselbe wie in Fukushima. Und unterscheidet sich das technologisch grundlegend, die Art und Weise der, sagen wir mal, der Zwischenlagerung an den AKWs in Deutschland gegenüber dem von Fukushima? Oder ist das eigentlich im Wesentlichen dasselbe?
Ne, wir haben da ein ganz anderes Prinzip. Und da bin ich auch ein bisschen stolz drauf, dass ich das stark mit durchgesetzt habe. Wenn auch nicht erfunden habe. Wir haben für die Brennelemente in den ersten fünf Jahren haben wir auch solche Lagerbecken wie in Fukushima. In Fukushima sind die aber so nachdem, was so jetzt der Stand ist, den die deutsche Expertenwelt gestern hatte, sind da eher pro Reaktor die Brennelemente aus den letzten 15 Jahren also deutlich mehr gelagert. Und die haben noch, was jetzt in der öffentlichen Diskussion noch nicht klar ist, noch eine siebte Anlage auf dem Gelände, nämlich ein großes Lagergebäude, wo die noch älteren, die fahren ja seit 40 Jahren oder 30 Jahren, je nachdem welcher Block. Und bei dem siebten, bei dem zentralen Lager müssen so um die 6000 Brennelemente drin stehen. Das ist auch noch mal ein Kühlungsproblem.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das, wo auf dem Satellitenbild oben rechts, wo die vielen Klimaanlagen drauf sind. Okay, also das heißt, die in Deutschland wird für fünf Jahre gelagert und dann umgelagert?
Und dann geht es in Kastoren.
Okay, also die Menge ist begrenzt, die in diesem Becken liegt?
Ja, ja. Sobald sie so weit abgekühlt sind, dass man die in Kastoren einfüllen kann, gehen die in Kastoren und gehen auf das Zwischenlager im Werksgelände. Und der Unterschied ist, in Kastor, da ist natürlich dieselbe Wärme drin, aber der ist als passives Gebilde so gemacht, dass er eigentlich ein großer Stahlbehälter, also es ist was anderes als Stahl, aber eine Eisenlegierung, dass der Kühlriben hat. Das heißt, das einzige, was ich bei so einem Lagerbehälter brauche, ist Luft, die dran vorbei streicht. Die Oberfläche der Kühlriben ist so berechnet, dass der Austausch langt dabei. Das heißt, es ist auch auf dem deutschen Kernkraftwerksgelände, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel nach Biblis gehe, dann habe ich da zwei Reaktoren. Gleiches Problem, ich habe zwei Lagerbecken mit relativ wenig Belegung, weil alles, was älter als fünf Jahre ist, ist raus. Und ich habe das Zwischenlager mit den Kastoren. Wenn wir jetzt mal unterstellen, wir hätten im Biblis einen schweren Unfall, dann müsste ich mich um die beiden Reaktoren kümmern. Ich müsste mich auch um die beiden Lagerbecken kümmern. Die sind aber weniger belegt, also weniger warm, nicht null warmer, aber weniger warmer. Aber ich müsste mich nicht um die Kastoren kümmern.
Wie ist denn, wenn jetzt durch einen, sagen wir mal, da bricht jetzt ein Feuer aus, und daneben gibt es eine Kernschmelze und die Luft, die bei den Kastoren ankommt, ist schon vorgewärmt? Also reicht jede Luft, oder sollte die, so sagen wir, 20 Grad haben, Umgebungstemperatur?
Nee, da sind schon Extremsituationen mit eingerechnet. Das ist A und B, selbst wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass man den thermisch völlig isoliert, also man überhäuft ihn mit Isoliermaterial, dann dauert es ganz viele Stunden, also in der Preisklasse von vielen Tagen sogar, also ein paar hundert Stunden auf jeden Fall, bis ich an Temperaturen komme, bei denen die Dichtung möglicherweise ein Problem kriegt. Also die Dichtung hat erst bei ein paar hundert Grad Probleme. Das heißt, ich habe einen ganz langen Zeitpuffer dabei. Wenn ich jetzt nur den Fall diskutiere, jetzt wegen Brand kommt heiße Luft, also dass dann Luft mit 80 oder 150 Grad vorbeikommt, habe ich ja immer noch einen Wärmeübergang. Ist also kühl besser als thermische Isolierung. Und bei thermischer Isolierung, die Sachen sind gerechnet worden. Und es ist sogar auch Flugzeugabsturz gerechnet worden. Jetzt nicht die Frage der Impact, sondern die Frage, was macht der folgende Brand? Und die Brände, die man mit normalen Treibstoffmengen hinkriegt, die langen noch nicht aus. Also der Castor steht sozusagen im Feuer. Die langen noch nicht aus, diese kritischen Temperaturen für die Kühlung hinzubekommen.
Was sind denn jetzt eigentlich noch die Optionen, die da in Japan haben, eigentlich nur noch zu schütten?
Also die haben eigentlich jetzt mal grob gesprochen, noch die Versuchsoption, so viel Wasser wie möglich hinzubekommen. Wobei man sich wirklich klar machen muss, wir reden über drei Reaktorkerne mit ernsten Problemen und wir reden über sechs, vielleicht sogar sieben Brennelementbecken mit ernsten Problemen. Und gewonnen ist nur, wenn jedes einzelne von den Sachen eingefangen ist. Also man darf sich nicht einbilden, wenn jetzt die Kühlung...
Ich mach jetzt die Hälfte und dann ist gut, ja?
Ja, also jedes einzelne Ding kann zu einer Katastrophe führen. Das heißt, ich muss schon allein von der Anzahl hinbekommen. Also deswegen Wasser rein kriegen, eine Hoffnung, aber das sieht nicht toll aus. Zweite Hoffnung, an dem ja die TEPCO-Kollegen noch arbeiten, eine Stromleitung wieder hinzukriegen, um Pumpen wieder in Betrieb zu nehmen. Das hängt aber davon ab, ob die überhaupt noch was Sinnvolles machen.
Die Ventile sind ja teilweise auch schon vielleicht...
Also wenn man auf die Satellitenbilder guckt, da sind so viele abgerossene Rohrleitungen und so.
Also der Strom nützt nur noch dort was, wo das System, das sich dann mit dem Strom antreibt, noch was Sinnvolles machen kann. Und da habe ich auch Augezweifel. Und das Zuschüten ist dann schon die nächste Geschichte, weil es ist ja immer noch so, dass, glaube ich, deutlich über 99 Prozent von dem radioaktiven Inventar in der Anlage ist. Also all das, was man stark erhöhter Radioaktivität gesehen haben, ist nur ein minimaler Bruchteil von dem, was freisetzbar ist. Das heißt, die Strahlenlage ist auch nur eine Minimalversion von dem, was am schlimmstenfalls möglich ist.
Das haben wir ja schon an den Messwertunterschehen zu Tschernobyl, bei den Hubschraubermessern zum Beispiel. Die waren ja so Faktor 500 geringer als Tschernobyl.
Ja. Also jetzt mal überschlagen mit den Daten, wie viel Brennstäbe da jetzt rumliegen. Wie viel Wärme müsste man jetzt herwegkühlen, wenn man es ordentlich machen wollte? Also ich meine, wie viel Wasser, das ist die nächste Frage, wie viel Wasser müsste man da überhaupt hinkriegen, um das weggekühlt zu kriegen? Weil das klingt jetzt nicht so realistisch.
Man kann jetzt da keine Antwort drauf geben, wo man jetzt sagt, 10.000 m³ oder 500 oder so, weil das Problem ist ja, wir sind ja außerhalb der normalen Kühlbarkeit. Das heißt, wir haben Stellen, nehmen wir mal das Reaktorbecken im Block 5 oder Block 6 oder dieses zentrale Lager auf dem Gelände, da sind die Brennelemente wahrscheinlich noch im Wasser. Wenn die Kühlung nicht läuft, verdunstet ihr erst mal aus dem Lagerbecken, das sind relativ große Wassermengen, weil ich muss die Brennelemente im Normalbetrieb 7 Meter überdeckt haben. Und spannend wird es erst, wenn sich unterer Oberkante Brennelemente kommen im Wasserspiegel. Also habe ich einen Puffer.
Wobei die Amerikaner ja meinten, dass bei den Erdbeben schon was rausgesloscht sein könnte.
Das ist jetzt die nächste Frage. Hab ich nur Verdunstung oder habe ich nur das Schwappen beim Erdbeben, dann ist es relativ harmlos. Da muss ich eigentlich so viel Wasser reinschaffen, dass ich den Wasserspügel über ein Brennelementen erhalte und plus einen halben Tag Verdunstung, dann kann ich mich mal wieder ein paar Stunden um was anderes kümmern. Aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwo einen Riss drin hab oder Leitungen so blöd hängen, dass ich über Süffungseffekte oder so Wasserverlust hab, sieht es schlechter aus. Punkt eins, Punkt zwei. Und das ist wahrscheinlich die Situation, die wir im Block vier haben. Da sind ja die Brennelemente zumindest zeitweise schon trocken gewesen. Das heißt, der Wasserspiegel war niedriger als oberkante Brennelemente. Da ist ja dann die Frage, kriege ich Wasser wieder rein? Das ist ja nicht so einfach, wenn ich ein paar hundert Grad heiße Konfigurationen Wasser reinkriegen muss. Und was mache ich da? Also was stelle ich da an? Weil ich habe jetzt freisetzungsfähiges Material durch die abgebrannten oder zersprungenen oder was auch immer Brennelementhylrohr.
Und was passiert, wenn ich da das Wasser überhaupt drauf kippe?
Ja.
Kann es sein, dass ich dadurch erst den Zirkoniumbrand los trete? Oder eine Gasexplosion auslöse? Ich meine, was ist denn da das Problem?
Es kann alles Mögliche sein. Wenn ich mich jetzt auf die Frage Nebenwirkungen gehe, dann muss ich mir die Fragen stellen. Aber wenn ich mal auf die Hauptwirkung gehe, es ist auch die Frage, wie viel das Wasser kühlt ja praktisch nur über seine Verdampfungswärmer. Also es kann so viel aufnehmen, bis es verdampft ist. Und das heißt, wie viel Wasser kriege ich an die heißen Stellen? Weil alles, was Wasserverlust ist, also wenn ich es nebendran schüte, und das hat man ja bei den Hubschrauberbildern gesehen, dass der nicht besonders schön getroffen war, das ist ja auch nicht wirksam. Ich kann ja nicht gezielt das allein reinbringen, deswegen steht ja auch die Idee mit den Feuerlöschkanonen, weil die in der Hoffnung, dass ich sozusagen mehr anwendbares Wasser oder mehr wirksames Wasser rein kriege.
Was uns so aufgefallen ist in dieser ganzen Geschichte, ist, dass die Informationspolitik des Betreibers ja schon eher sowjetische Züge trägt.
Also das glaube ich nicht an der Stelle.
Oder wissen die einfach zu wenig?
Der Betreiber ist, ich meine seine Bulletanks sind schrecklich zu lesen, aber er gibt so mit 5-6 Stunden Verzug vernünftige Informationen. Jetzt natürlich nur für Fachleute. Also erstens, man kann bei den Reaktorkanonen, konnte man seit die überhitzt sind, auf jeden Fall nicht feststellen, in welchem Zustand die sind, sondern nur von Indizien ausgehen. Ich habe ja keine Möglichkeit ins containment und in die Reaktortruppe-Hälter rein zu gucken. Also ich habe jetzt nur solche Indizien, wie wir vor längerer Zeit besprochen haben, wenn über 800 Grad dann Wasserstoffbildung, wenn Wasserstoff rauskommt, offensichtlich kann über 800 Grad zumindest teilweise. Oder wenn Caesium in großen Mengen rauskommt, wenn ich das auf meiner Messumgebungsmessung sehe, dann muss halt die entsprechende Hitze im Brennelement sein, die noch ein ganzes Stück höher ist, damit ich auf solche freigesetzten Caesiummengen komme, was ich aus den theoretischen Studien weiß. Aber mehr ist aus dem containment und aus dem Reaktor kann nicht an Info zu kriegen. Es gibt vielleicht noch eine, die man auch erwähnen sollte, weswegen die jetzt denken, dass im Block 2 das containment möglicherweise kaputt ist. Wenn ich jetzt versuche, Wasser reinzupumpen und es bleibt da nicht stabil drin, kann ich natürlich die Vermutung haben, dass es irgendwo wieder rausläuft, an einer Stelle, die ich bisher nicht gekannt habe. Also Leck, Zerstörung, Riss, was weiß ich. Aber mehr Infos gibt es da nicht.
Ist das inhärent oder haben die das einfach nur, weil das so ein altes Kraftwerk ist?
Also wir haben bisher in den meisten Kernkraftwerken weltweit und auch in Deutschland durchaus nur entweder gar keine oder wenig Instrumentation für solche völlig auslegungsüberschreitenden Fälle. Man muss sich ja vorstellen, man muss erstmal glauben, dass das passiert. Da muss man als Betreiber akzeptieren, dass die Behörde eine Auflage machen darf für solche Fälle. Die haben sich ja Betreiber in Deutschland auch massiv dagegen gewehrt. Und dann muss ich mir noch ausdenken, was könnte da vernünftig sein? Weil, wenn man mit so einer Hitze, mit so überall Dampfatmosphären, mit Explosionswellen umgeht, heißt das ja nicht, dass ich da ein normaler Messmimik nehmen kann, sondern die muss ich ja speziell auslegen. Also es gibt Kataloge, wo man reinschreibt, als Nachrüstforderungen, zum Beispiel ist auch im Papier vom Bundesumweltministerium vom September schon festgeschrieben, dass man eigentlich eine Aufrüstung braucht bei dieser Beobachtung, falls man in diesen, falls man in solchen schweren Fällen ist. Aber der Katalog ist lange nicht umgesetzt.
Das heißt, was wir da gerade sehen, ist weniger absichtliches Vertuschen als tatsächliches Nichtwissen.
Ja.
Das ist ja schon deprimierend, oder?
Wissen.
Wie ist denn das jetzt gerade, man kriegt, also die CDU fährt gerade so eine Strategie zu sagen, naja, die Japaner, die haben halt alte Schrottreaktoren. Das hat ja bei Tschernobyl auch funktioniert als Verteidigungslinie erst mal. Wie sieht denn das aus Sicht eines Reaktorexperten aus? Ist das eine gültige Ausrede oder sieht das bei uns eigentlich genauso aus?
Also wir haben ja hier in Deutschland auch einen sehr unterschiedlichen Stand. Also wir haben Kernkraftwerke, die haben vier Notstromdiesel. Wir haben aber auch einzelne Ausnahmen, die keine vier Notstromdiesel haben, bei denen seit vielen Jahren darüber diskutiert wird, ob man dem armen Betreiber wirklich zumuten kann, da mal ein System mit vier Notstromdieseln und entsprechenden gesicherten Verteilungen aufzubauen oder ob es gerade noch tolerierbar ist. Ich muss an der Stelle mal so zynisch sagen. Und wir haben eine ganze Menge Keinkraftwerke, bei denen die Diskussion im Raum steht. Brauchen wir ein verbunkertes vierfaches Notstandssystem, bei dem die Systeme besser geschützt sind und auch besser mit Stromerzeugungsmöglichkeiten, Wasservorräten versehen sind oder nicht. Also insofern ist es jetzt nicht so, dass bei uns jedes Keinkraftwerk an der, also eine volle Ausrüstung an Sicherheitssystemen hat, die man sich heutzutage vorstellt. Es ist auch so, dass jedes Keinkraftwerk, was wir haben, auch die neuesten, jetzt heute zum Beispiel in Finnland nicht genehmigungsfähig wäre. Finnland baut ja gerade einen neuen Reaktor, also nach den Maßstäben, die die finden, dort anlegen, wäre auch das neueste deutsche Keinkraftwerk nicht genehmigungsfähig.
Ja, also welche Optionen haben denn die Japaner jetzt, wenn sie die Kühlung nicht in den Griff bekommen? Also wie kann man sich so einen Zuschütten vorstellen? Der Reaktor, also die Reaktoren sind ja viele und es ist ja groß. Und das wäre dann schon ein bisschen mehr als der Sacko-Fahrkonsernobil, den man da bräuchte.
Also grundsätzlich ist es ja so, es ist weit über 99 Prozent vom Inventar noch drin. Wenn jetzt alle diese Kühlmöglichkeiten versagen, wird es früher oder später zur Freisetzung kommen. Und die Freisetzung kann schlagartig sein, wenn noch mal irgendwie Dampfexplosion, Wasserstoff-Explosion oder so was mitspielt. Die kann aber auch über Wochen, also man muss sich ja vorstellen, wenn die Schmelze auch kühler ist, also auch wieder fest ist, setzt sie ja trotzdem radioaktive Stoffe frei. Also wäre sozusagen eine Quelle, die ja dann, wenn sie erstarrt ist, dann vielleicht wieder nur 1800 oder 1600 Grad oder nach einiger Zeit auch nur 1500 Grad hat und da dampfen ja laufend radioaktive Stoffe draus aus. Und jetzt vor dem Szenario, dass ich, wenn die Kühlung versagt, über Wochen eine Quelle offen an der Atmosphäre liegen habe, aus der immer weiter ausdampft und aus der ja noch viel mehr ausdampfen kann, als jetzt schon rausgekommen ist, da ist eine Überlegung, wenn ich es schaffe, dann drei Meter Überdeckung, was auch immer das ist, hin so drüber zu werfen, dann kommen halt vielleicht nicht 50 Prozent raus, sondern nur ein Prozent. Was für die Frage, wen es alles direkt trifft, schon eine Rolle spielt.
Also die werden dann halt irgendwann da zu Sand und Beton greifen müssen?
Also ich vermute mal, also mit einer relativ hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie dorthin kommen. Die Kühlversuche sollte man natürlich so lange probieren, wie es geht, weil Kühlung ist besser als nur Überdeckung.
Spielt für die Gefahr eine Rolle, wie nah die beieinander sind? Also wird das Problem größer, wenn da, wenn sagen wir, die Kühlbecken direkt nebeneinander liegen oder wenn da 100 Meter zwischen sind?
Also wenn man die Frage so stellt, ob man noch irgendwelche Reparatur oder Maßnahmen machen kann, natürlich schon, weil die Strahlung, also das, was an Strahlung auf dem Gelände jetzt ist und was auch an Strahlung sein wird, wenn es sich weiterentwickelt, machen natürlich alle Quellen, also alle Lagerbecken und alle Reaktoren zusammen. Und die kann da, also es kann schwieriger sein, auch irgendwelche Maßnahmen, egal Hubschrauber, Löschfahrzeuge oder dort rumlaufen und noch schnell was montieren, ist schlimmer. Für die Frage, wie die Freisetzung geht, glaube ich, dass es recht wenig Einfluss hat, weil das ist direkt die Frage, ob der Haufen, der vom Reaktor 1 übrig bleibt oder der Haufen, der vom Brennalumentlagerbecken 4 übrig bleibt, was der freisetzt, hängt jetzt wenig von den Wechselwirkungen mit dem Nachbarhaufen ab.
Und es gab ja, also bevor vor Kurse jemand passiert ist, gab es ja so ein bisschen Diskussionen, ob es jetzt eine nukleare renaissance gibt, ob man nicht cleverer Reaktordesigns machen kann, halt wie zum Beispiel diese Thorium-Kugelhaufen-Reaktor und ähnliche Dinge. Und wir sind ja da so ein bisschen naiv rangeguckt, haben uns das mal so ein bisschen angeguckt und dann fand ich da diesen Hochtemperatur-Thorium-Reaktor, den sie...
Das liest sich immer richtig toll. Also wir haben die Propaganda gelesen, ja und dann denken wir, boah, das ist ja prima und da kann man ja viel mehr Brennstoff mit ausnutzen und dann steht da immer so Sachen dran, wie inhärent sicher, aber das haben die eigentlich immer bei allen der Actual Designs behauptet, über die Jahre und dann kommt man unten zu den Gegeneinzeigen und da stehen dann so Sachen wie bei den schnellen Brütern, dass die nicht eigenstabil sind und dass man da halt eingreifen muss und dass die nicht von alleine ausgeht werden, die versehentlich überkritisch werden, unsere Sachen dann denken wir so, vielleicht doch keine gute Idee. Wie sieht das denn aus Ihrer Sicht aus?
Also die meisten von den Reaktorkonzepten, die da als Generation 4, Generation 4 oder ähnliche Dinge diskutiert werden, sind eigentlich irgendwelche Varianten von schnellen Brütern und die sind aus kernphysikalischen Gründen, so wie gerade eben gesagt, besonders instabil. Das ist das eine Problem, das andere ist, sie funktionieren eigentlich alle mit metallischem Kühlmittel, das heißt mit Flüssigmetallen, Atrium ist die bekanntere Variante, es gibt auch Varianten mit Blei. Ich frage mich, wie dann bei einer Auslegungsüberschreitung mit dem Brennen ein Kühlmittel, weil die brennen ja sofort an Luft, wie man da noch irgendwas machen will oder ob man da, genauso wie bei Tschernobyl, dort war der Graphit als Moderator sozusagen, das treibende Brandmittel, ob man für solche Fälle dann halt Flüssigmetall, also brennendes Flüssigmetall als Treibmittel nehmen soll. Wenn man jetzt zum Hochtemperaturreaktor geht, der ist physikalisch kein so ein großes Problem, weil der sich relativ gut stabilisiert. Der hat aber zwei massive Probleme. Der stabilisiert sich auch in den kleinen Einheiten, die da in Diskussion waren, also 80 Megawatt und solche Größen, also deutlich eher beim Zehntel der heutigen Reaktoren von der Größe. Der stabilisiert sich dann bei 15, 16 Hundert Grad. Und da ist der Grafit, der in großen Mengen drin ist, ist unheimlich empfindlich gegen Wasser. Das heißt, ich muss technologisch beherrschen, dass mir nicht ein Reaktor, der nach dem Kühlungsausfall in der Zone stehen bleibt, trotzdem Wasser aufs Grafit bekommt, weil dann erstens auch wieder die ganzen Wasserstofffragen sich stellen und zweitens, der Grafit schließt beim Hochtemperaturreaktor auch den Brennstoff ein. Natürlich, wenn der Grafit wegoxidiert wird durch Wasserdampf, dann die Rückhaltekraft auch kaputt geht. Das heißt, für schwere Unfälle bei einer massiven Einwirkung von außen zum Beispiel oder bei einer massiven Lekage zwischen dem zweiten Wasserkühlkreislauf und dem ersten Kreislauf, der dort mit Helium gekühlt wird, die ist auch nicht beherrschbar.
Also zu lesen war ja, dass dieser mit dem hohen Temperaturreaktor, für den gab es ein Prototyp mit Jülich, wo sie dann hinterher beim Abbau festgestellt haben, dass sie da etliche von diesen Brennelemente, Kugeln aus der gerissenen Grundplatte, aus irgendwelchen Rissen kratzen mussten. Und bei dem kommerziellen Betrieb, den sie 1989 eingestellt haben, von dem Hochtemperaturreaktor, war ja dann festgestellt worden, dass sie da massiv Brennelemente, also Brennkugeln zerstört hatten. Also irgendwie tausendmal mehr als irgendwie angenommen. Sind das so richtig grundlegende Probleme, weswegen man diese Reaktordesigns auch nicht sagen kann, dass man die sicher bekommen kann?
Also man muss aufpassen, wenn man sich solche Reaktordesigns von Physikern verkaufen lässt, weil die sehen nur den physikalischen Prozess. Aber gerade an den Temperaturtypen sind die realen Probleme an der ingenieurmäßigen Lösung. Das heißt, in Namenüntrop zum Beispiel diese tausendfach mehr Brennelementschäden ist schlicht ein Problem dadurch gewesen, dass man sich in Temperaturbereichen zwangsläufig bewegt bei diesem Reaktor, wo man nicht wirklich weiß, wie gut die Werkstoffe halten. Und es hat sich eben in der Praxis gezeigt, dass die Werkstoffe deutlich schlechter halten als davor. Bei Jülich, bei dem Versuchsreaktor, der ja seit, glaube ich, 68 gelaufen ist, kommt hinzu, einerseits hatten wir auch Probleme gehabt, die jetzt nicht vorhersehbar waren oder nicht vorhergesehen worden sind. Auf der anderen Seite hatten wir auch dort relativ wenig Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten gehabt, was wirklich im Kern passiert. Das heißt, wir sind heute verschiedene Leute, die sich damit genauer befassen in der Forschungsanlage oder an anderen Stellen. Wir sind jetzt am rückwärts überlegen, wieder eher aus Indizien, ob da zum Beispiel viel höhere Temperaturen aufgetreten sind, weil keine unter den Bedingungen brauchbare Temperaturmessungen für alle Zonen im Kern da war oder ob solche Dinge noch sind. Das ist jetzt eher reaktorhistorisch, aber in dem Augenblick, wo irgendjemand denkt, er müsste wieder ein Hochtemperaturreaktor bauen, sollte man diese Erfahrungen auch wirklich auswerten. Und da ist dann fraglich, ob der technisch gesehen der Sicherheitsgehalt wirklich drin ist, der physikalisch vorausgesehen wird.
Das ist also diese Propaganda, die da vorher lief, europäischer Kugelhaufen Reaktor und diese ganzen Sachen war de facto nur darauf aufbauend, wir haben ja schon alle vergessen, dass wir es schon mal ausprobiert haben oder?
Ne, es ist ja jetzt eher, also ich will jetzt kein Physiker oder Physikerin was zu leide tun, es ist halt, das physikalische Prinzip ist stark reizend, weil das wirklich besser aussieht, als bei den jetzt bestehenden Reaktoren. Und dass dann viele von den Leuten gesagt haben, lass uns doch noch mal probieren und lass uns dort probieren, wir kriegen einen Reaktor hin, der sicherer ist. Das war einfach ein Reiz, aber jetzt ist mein Eindruck eher aus den letzten drei, vier Jahren, dass der Reiz stark abnimmt. Also vor allem seit die Südafrikaner beschlossen haben, das war ja das einzige Land, was den weiterentwickelt hat die letzten 20 Jahre. Die haben vor jetzt vielen Monaten beschlossen, dass sie es nicht mehr finanzieren wollen, weil es offensichtlich auch kein wirtschaftliches Ergebnis hat.
Wie ist denn generell, kann man das verallgemeinern auf kleine Reaktoren generell? Das gab es ja als Konzeptidee, dass man den Strom viel dezentraler generiert, dass man irgendwie pro Häuserblock oder so einen kleinen Nuklearreaktor hat. Ist das generell eine schlechte Idee?
Also wenn man anständige Sicherheitssysteme macht, sind die bei kleinen Reaktoren nicht arg viel billiger als bei großen.
Okay, das ist die Frage abschließend beantwortet.
Ja, genau.
Okay, noch mal so vielleicht als Abschlussfrage. Sehen wir jetzt gerade tatsächlich das Ende des Atomzeitalters?
Also ich bin ja ein sehr vorsichtiger Mensch. Muss man ja auch als Sicherheitsingenieur sein. Da reden wir mal in zehn Jahren drüber.
Okay, ist also nicht auszuschließen, dass es doch noch mal irgendwie immer weitergeht?
Es ist weder das eine noch die andere Richtung auszuschließen. Also da will ich jetzt kein Prophet spielen.
Okay, alles klar.
Vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Vielen Dank fürs Interview, auch gerade unter erschwerten Bedingungen. Ihr wisst es sehr zu schätzen. Danke. Ja, das war Alternativlos, die Folge 14 zum Thema Atomsicherheit und Reaktoren Fukushima. Unser Gast auf der Hälfte der Sendung war Michael sailer vom Ueco-Institut in Freiburg, Mitglied der Reaktorsicherheitskommission. Wenn ihr jetzt noch irgendwie duran nachdenkt, dass ihr immer noch gut ein gewisses Strom verbrauchen könnt, dann könnt ihr vielleicht noch auf den Flatterbutton drücken. Ansonsten wünschen wir...
Wenn ihr nach dem Umstieg auf Ökostrom noch Geld habt.
Wenn ihr nach dem Umstieg auf Ökostrom noch Geld habt. Wir werden hoffentlich in einer nächsten Sendung mal über das Thema Was passiert denn jetzt eigentlich? Also wie stellen wir denn irgendwie unsere Energieversorgung um? Und was sind dann also die Folgen? Und wo muss man noch drauf achten? Reden, das wird sicher noch ein bisschen dauern, aber wir werden es sicherlich nicht aus dem Auge fallen. Ansonsten vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.